THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE A GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO A HEARING OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN.
TIME MERGES HERE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE THE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE. THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
CAPITAL. AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE VISITED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WE WILL BE USING TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARK
PARTICIPATING TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE HE WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TO. ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE EIGHT
THREE SIX FIVE SEVEN ONE. THREE
EIGHT THREE SIX FIVE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
NORTH COMMITTEE. WEBSITE WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT. PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAIT- WHICH IS JUST. WHAT WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT INTHE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON
MUTE IT AND YOU'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU. CLEARLY IN IT TO
AVOID ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU. WHEN WE WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TO REMEMBER TO MUTE YOUR PHONE
OR WHATEVER DEVICE. YOU'RE
USING WHEN YOU CALL AND- I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM OBVIOUSLY
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON AND
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM REPEATING
YOUR PRIOR TESTIMONY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RE LITIGATE. THE
POLICY MERITS OF THE BILLS JUST
FOCUS ON THE FISCAL IMPACTS.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MATTERS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE.
HEARD WE HAVE NINETY EIGHT
BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY HOME
THE TWO ITEMS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
DO PASSED MOM MOTIONS AND THE
REST. ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. ALL SB TWO EIGHT
ONE BY SENATOR DODD AND SB FOUR
FOUR ONE BY SENATOR HER TADO.
WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY SAID
THEY WILL BE SENT DIRECTLY TO
THE FOUR PERSON TO RULE TWENTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT. A FINAL NOTE
REGARDING THE ORDER OF THE
AGENDA- FIVE. SENATOR LIMON HAS
AN ACCOMMODATION TO MOVE A BILL
THE FRONT OF THE LINE SHE'S ONE
OF THE ONLY TWO AUTHORS WHO
WILL BE PRESENTING. ON A BILL
THIS MORNING AND SHE WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY V. AS IN
LENGTH. FROM HER DISTRICT
OFFICE SO FOR ALL OF THOSE
LISTENING- BEGIN HEARING WITH
SB TWO EIGHTY. SB TWO NINETY
THREE AND SB FIVE FORTY AFTER
THAT THE REMAINING AGENDA WILL
BE IN FILE ORDER AS DISPLAYED
ON OUR WEBSITE IN THE DAILY
FILE. AND AS A FINAL
ANNOUNCEMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS NOTIFIED THE
COMMITTEE THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
FILES OR COMMENTS FOR ANY THE
BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY SO WE
DO NOT HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PARTICIPATE. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS BUT
TO STAB A SHORT FORM MISTER
CONSULTANT IF YOU COULD CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR PORTANTINO.
I'M HERE PORTANTINO HERE BATES.
BRADFORD CENTER BRADFORD HERE
JONES- JONES HERE KAMLAGER
HERE. CAMARGO HERE CENTER
LAYERED HERE. LATER HERE ANSWER
MY COUNTY HERE. I COUNTY HERE
WITH SIX MONTHS WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO THANK YOU- DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARING- AND
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING. PROTOCOLS THEY'LL BE
A TIME LIMIT ON WITNESS
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES OF
TOTAL TIME FOR THEIR PRIMARY.
WITNESS TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TEST MY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION OF THE
MEASURE. IF NECESSARY WILL ALSO
LIMIT THE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR EACH
SIDE. AS A REMINDER ALL
WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS.
OF THE BILL- AND THE ME TOOS
WILL BE NAME. AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON. OKAY NOW MOVING TO
S. B. TWO. FIVE SENATORS AMOUNT
A LARGE GROUP HEALTH INSURANCE.
THIS FIRST ITEM. IS ELIGIBLE
FOR DO FAST MOTION AND WE AS
NOTED SENATOR RAMON IS ON SOON-
IS LIMóN ARE YOU THERE. I AM
THANK YOU CHAIR PLEASE TELL US
ABOUT SB TWO EIGHTY. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE
JOSEPHINE FIGUEROA FROM THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LAW LARA'S OFFICE ON THE CO
HOST MINUS YOUR PRIMARY SPORT
WITNESS ON THIS BILL AS WELL SO.
THANK YOU THINK CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT IT UNTIL IF YOU
COULD LET US KNOW IF YOU HAVE A
STAFFER IN THE ROOM WITH YOU. I
DO. I AM IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE
IN SANTA BARBARA AND I HAVE
BEEN A LITTLE BIT IN THE OFFICE
WITH ME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TURN MEMBERS SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY WOULD REQUIRE LARGE
GROUP MARKET HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICIES TO COVER MEDICALLY
NECESSARILY. NECESSARY BASIC
HEALTH CARE SERVICES INDIVIDUAL
AND SMALL GROUP MARKET HEALTH
INSURANCE REGULATED BY THE HELP
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. LARGE GROUP MARKET
HEALTH INSURANCE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO COVER MEDICALLY
NECESSARILY. BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AS A RESULT OUR-
LARGE GROUP POLICIES ROUTINELY
LIMIT OR EXCLUDE COVERAGE FROM
THE CENTRAL MEDICAL CARE SUCH
AS WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES OBESITY CARE ORGAN
TRANSPLANTS. SB TWO EIGHTY WILL
ALSO CODIFY THE FEDERAL
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT PROHIBITION
ON DISCRIMINATORY LANGUAGE. FOR
GROUP. HEALTH INSURANCE
BENEFITS DESIGN AND MARKETING
PRACTICES THIS PROTECTION
PROHIBITS HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES FROM DISCOURAGING
CONSUMERS WITH SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH NEEDS FROM ENROLLING IN
COVERAGE AND ALSO PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST.
CONSUMERS BASED ON PROTECTED
CHARACTERISTICS THESE INCLUDE
RACE COLOR NATIONAL ORIGIN
PRESENTED OR PREDICTIVE
PREDICTED DISABILITY AGE SEX
EXPECTED LENGTH OF LIFE. DEGREE
OF MEDICAL DEPENDENCY QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR OTHER HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND AS YOU STATED-
WE DO HAVE JUST A FEW BURGER I
DEFEAT LEGISLATOR FOR WORK.
DONE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE HERE TO SPEAK WITH ANY.
SUPPORT TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SENATOR- MISS
FIGUEROA ARE YOU THERE MISTER
MODERATE YES I AM RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
JOSEPHINE FIGUEROA GET THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. WE ARE
THE PROUD SPONSORS OF IT YOU
EIGHTY WANTED THANK SYNERGY
MULLIN- FOR OFFERING THE BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SB TWO
EIGHTY HAS NO GENERAL FUND
IMPACT AND MINOR CALL TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE- AND IT
WOULD REMOVE DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES IN THE LARGE GROUP
INSURANCE MARKET BY REQUIRING
LARGE GROUP MARKET HEALTH
INSURANCE POLICIES. TO COVER
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BASIC
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- THE BILL
ALSO CALLED UPON. BY THE
FEDERAL AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
MISSION ON DISCRETE. PRACTICES
BASED ON. IDENTITY RACE COLOR
NATIONAL ORIGIN DISABILITY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION WITH RESPECT
TO A LARGE GROUP INSURANCE
POLICIES. EXPANSION OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION UNIT BETWEEN IT WILL
HELP ENSURE CONSUMERS WHO ARE
COVERED BY LARGE GROUP HEALTH
INSURANCE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SAME BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AS MILLIONS OF OTHER
CALIFORNIANS ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER TO
BABBLE NADA I LEFT FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISS
FOR YOUR OWN OUR MOVE TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- THERE'S NO
ONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THAT I SEE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY. SO WILL NOW
MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE- GOOD MORNING MR
MODERATOR MS MODERATOR PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
EIGHTY. AND LET ME KNOW THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF FOLKS IF YOU
KNOW. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
BECAUSE SUPPORT OF SB TWO
EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD TO BEGIN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ONE PERSON IN
Q. WHO CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
THEY'VE ACTUALLY TAKEN
THEMSELVES OUT OF QUEUE. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN HERE FOR SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION- THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. SEVENTY
ROOM TWENTY FOUR FORTY-
MODERATOR FEW WOULD PROMPT ANY
OPPOSITION NOW WOULD BE THE
TIME. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO EIGHTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
TWO EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE NO. MONEY AND
OPPOSITION BRING BACK TO THE
MEMBERS MR LAYERED AS A
QUESTION. I HAVE A COMMENT. AS
SUCH. AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY- THERE WERE A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOR NON
DISCRIMINATION CODE SECTIONS.
THAT WERE NOT UPDATED THEY WERE
OF. ONLY TWO HAD SEXUAL
ORIENTATION MANY DIDN'T HAVE
GENDER MANY SAID ETHNIC
HERITAGE INSTEAD OF RACE OR
COLOR. AND I WENT THROUGH
OVERSATURATION OF FIVE
DIFFERENT BILLS. AND INDEX THEM
TO THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT THERE WERE TEN OR
FIFTEEN THAT I COULDN'T DO AND
MANY OF THEM WERE IN THE
INSURANCE FEAR. AND THAT'S WHAT
IS BEING ADDRESSED HERE SO ON
THE POLICY LEVEL WHICH WE'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IS THE RIGHT THING BUT EVERY
TIME YOU DO THIS IT HAS TO
ACTUALLY BE ENFORCED WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF ASSISTED PHYSICS. IS
THE FISCAL ISSUE IT'S DE
MINIMUS. AND DOES SO I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
PASS TODAY AND WHEN THE TIME IS
READY I WILL MOVEMENT. THANK
YOU MR LEHRER. BISLAMA WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE. I WILL TAKE AT
MY COLLEAGUES COME INTO AS A
CLOSING AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SAID TO MY COLLEAGUE- FROM THE
CENTRAL COAST FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND I RESPECT THE
ASPIRIN. MISTER CHAIR I MOVE
THE BILL THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND MR SECRETARY WOULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL. SB TWO
EIGHTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO HI
BATES BRADFORD. EFFORT HI JONES
JONES FIVE COM LONGER AYE
COBBLER AYE LAYERED AYE LAYERED
HI MY COUNTY HI KELSEY I HAVE
SIX OF ALL RIGHT THAT HAS SIX
VIRTUAL HOLD ON CALL FROM HIS
FATE SO WE MOVE ON TO THANK YOU
MISTER MOM- WILL MOVE ON TO S.
B. TWO NINETY THREE WHICH THE
AUTHOR HAS. WAIVED HER
OPPORTUNITY THE BONE TESTIFIED
IT IS A- SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SO
LET'S GO TO- TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINE THREE
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM THERE IS
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP ANYBODY ON THE LINE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINETY THREE.
AND MEDIC CAL SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. I'D BE GLAD TO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH BECAUSE THE PORT OF SB TWO
NINE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AT THE TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
BECAUSE THE PORT OF SB TWO NINE
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BECAUSE IT
SHOWS WE HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORTER PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWO NINETY
THREE- NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NO. MATTER IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO NINETY
THREE. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINE
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THE GO.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINE
THREE MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. SAYING NO
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO NINETY
THREE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
WILL MOVE ON TO MR MOANS NEXT
BILL. WHICH IS SB FIVE FORTY ON
IMPROVING PEOPLE SUCCESS A
GRANT PROGRAM. THIS IS ALSO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- NO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FORTY. BY
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FORTY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FORTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK AT THE PORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THIS COMPANY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. HE COULD QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE
FORTY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE FORTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FORTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT THE
SEEING NO OPPORTUNITY OR SAYING
NO ONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION SINGH NO
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
FORTY. IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. WILL MOVE NOW TO SB FOUR
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. ON THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND- AND DELICATE THE DISABLED
TELLING TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROGRAM SURCHARGES- IS GONZALEZ
HAS WAY PRESENTATION AND THE
ITEM IS ALSO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. FOR ANYONE IN THERE
ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S OR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY I SEE NONE.
SEE NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR. YES LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WIH
BECAUSE SUPPORT OF S. B. FOR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NEVER MIND OR IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE PERSON IN THE QUEUE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
THE MESSAGE. ALL
RIGHT OKAY TO FIND THEM ON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WILL BE ONE MOMENT. I WILL OPEN
MY NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ENJOY A STERLING
FROM THE RURAL CAUCUS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
MORE PERSON IN Q. THEY'RE
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBERS THAN
ACTUAL LAW AND YOU CAN OPT
EDUCATION. SH THE LADIES IN
GERMAN I DON'T REMINDER IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. BEFORE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL MORE PERSON IN Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE ARE CURRENTLY
WITH OPERATORS.
THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LANE
VIOLATION. UGH IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. AND THANKS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHTY ONE NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
TERROR MEMBERS RON RAPP
THINKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE ARE. CO SPONSORS OF AS FAR I
REQUEST IN MY BOOK THANK YOU.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. BEFORE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE OF IMPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WATER IF
YOU TO OF ANY OPPOSITION S. B.
FOR NOW WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AS BEFORE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION- ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM THE SPORT IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO HANDS FOR
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS BEFORE. WE GO TO SUSPENSE
TO MOVE ONTO OUR NEXT BILL. BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ S. B. TWO
FORTY FIVE ON HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. ABORTION SERVICES AND
COST SHARING. THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE. CANDIDATE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
NOW SEE OPPORTUNITY AND I SEE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES. AND
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE AND THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TENTY FORTY. MODERATE UP
THE SUPPORT FOR SB TWO FOUR
FIVE NOW WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO FOUR FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
IN CUBA CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE
RATING FOR THAT LINE ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK OF THE
PORT OF SB TWO FOUR FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
LINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ALEXANDRA
CAMERA AND I CALL YOU- I'M
CALLING TO URGE YOU. TO VOTE
YES ON SB TWO FORTY FIVE I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB WO FOUR FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WILL NOW
MOVE ON OPPOSITION. SB TWO FOUR
FIVE. NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE SOMEBODY IN ROOM. FORTY
TWO OR THREE ADDITIONAL IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
GIVE UP ANYONE OPPOSED S. B.
TWO FOUR FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FOUR
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
ABOUT THREE IN Q. THERAPY JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE. I CAN IMAGINE
SOME OF THE COSTA DIRECTOR.
OPEN MY NUMBER SIXTY NINE MY TO
CLEAN UP YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO COMMITTEE AND GRANGER BUT
CHINA MY NAME IS ROBERT BYRD
AND AN ORGANIZER WITH PRO LIFE
SAN FRANCISCO AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NOW ON SB. TWO FORTY FIVE.
LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE EIGHT. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS BY EIGHTY SEVEN LINE IS NOW
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS STAPLETON
I'M CALLING ON- IN REGARDS TO
SUPPORT FOR SB FORTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY ALSO.
ATTACHED SUPPORT IF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY A
YESTERDAY AND ALSO IS PUBLIC
POLICY OFFICER FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD MALE CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
WE ARE ALL IN SUPPORT FOR A
SPEECH. YOU FOR FINE THANK YOU.
AND BEFORE WE OPEN LINE NUMBER
FIFTY TWO AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO FOUR FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS TONY ROAD BALANCE WITH
CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE. SB.
TWO FORTY FIVE. ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
THERESA BRENNAN FROM THE RIGHT
LIVELEAK OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB. TWO
FORTY FIVE. BLIND EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE- THIS IS THAT NAY
AROUND PRO CHOICE AMERICA IN-
THE COURT APOLOGIES FOR DOING
THIS I ON THE OPPOSITE LINE
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FOUR
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION- ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM THE SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. OF SB TWO FOUR
FIVE SING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO FOUR
FIVE. MOVED TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO OUR NEXT BILL. WHICH IS
SB THREE THREE EIGHT. NINE
JOINT AND SEVERAL SEVERAL
LIABILITY OF PORT- THREE THREE
H. MOTOR CARRIERS COSTUMERS.
ALL RIGHT THIS IS SENATOR
GONZALEZ AS WELL SHE'S REYES
WAVE PRESENTATION AND AS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. IT'S
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
SOMEBODY IN TWENTY FORTY THE
MODERATOR COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF SB. THREE THREE
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF%
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE THREE EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YES WE DO
HAVE ONE PERSON IN SUPPORT TO
BE JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND
IT APPEARS THAT PRESIDENT
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM THE
BUREAU. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
EIGHT SAYING NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. OF ANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATE IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE THREE EIGHT. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE THREE EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
THREE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT AVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE THREE EIGHT.
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
TO SB SIX. THIRTY FIVE ON CLEAN
UP ACTIVITIES ON STATE HIGHWAYS
RIGHT OF WAY OFF RAMPS AND
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS. SB SIX
THIRTY FIVE IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND SENATOR GONZALEZ
IS WAY PRESENTATION. IT'S TIME
FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
SEEING NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
SYNCING KNOWN IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. THE MOVE TO TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE IF YOU Q.
OF ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
THREE FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX THREE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX THREE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I SHOULD KNOW WHEN IT'S
SUPPORTER. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
MOVE ON THE OPPOSITION. THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE GIVE
ANYONE OPPOSED XP SP THREE SIX
THREE FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX THREE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX THREE FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT THIS
TIME. AND WE SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SIX THREE FIVE ABOUT A
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SENATOR
SKINNER US FOR BILLS. STOPPARD
WAY PRESENTATION ON ALL FOUR
FIRST UP IS SB SIXTEEN ON PEACE
OFFICERS RELEASE OF RECORDS. WE
WILL OPEN UP THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THIS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTEEN. THING NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. OP MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD. QUEUE OF ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER. YES- LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE
IN Q. GIVE ME ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHINE WHINE THIRTY TOOK
YOURSELF OUT A CUTIE WITH TO
SPEAK OF THE PORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. WHY TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE WOULD BE
FANTASTIC ON BEHALF OF EIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND TAX
OPEN LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER DISBURSING THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTER SB SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS DWAYNE
RIGHTS AND I'M A MILITARY
VETERAN AND MEMBER OF VETERANS
WALK AND TALK I'M IN SUPPORT SB.
SIXTEEN AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ACTIVE TIME. WE HAVE ONE
MORE PERSON IN Q. CURRENTLY
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CLOSE JAMES WOOD
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENT
IN SUPPORT OF THE SB SIXTY
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS COLIN
WHILE US ARMY INFANTRY VETERAN
AND FOUNDER OF VETERANS WALKIE
TALKIE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. BY NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHRAN
RAP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STOCKS TO
DISSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. CAN ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE TO
MORE PEOPLE DISPUTE UP. BY
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT NOT RESPONSIBLE ONE TO THE
NEXT LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIFTY ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS NICOLE WITH EASE CALLING IN
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
JAMES WOOD COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
RENDON PRESIDENT PRINCIPLE OR
OF SB SIXTY THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH BECAUSE
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR SB
SIXTEEN. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT THERE. ALL RIGHT MOVING
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTEEN. NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THE COMPANY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE FTQ OF
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO
WISHES TO OPPOSE SB SIXTEEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE SB SIXTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WITH NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION FOR. ALL
RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES GO UP S. B.
SIXTEEN. WILL GO TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. LIVING ON THE S. B.
EIGHTY ONE ALSO BY SENATOR
SKINNER ON SENTENCING DISMISSAL
AND ENHANCEMENTS- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION- NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
AT THE MICROPHONE NATIONALLY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MATTER IF
COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE WISHING
TO SUPPORT SB EIGHTY ONE. YES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE TWO PEOPLE
IN QB ONE MOMENT PLEASE. BY
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF YOUR MIND IS MUTED OR
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. BUT NO
RESPONSE OPEN MY NUMBER NINETY
FIVE NINE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINETY FIVE YES MA'AM
THAT'S YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS CAROLINE
STAPLETON DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION FOR THE PEACE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. IT
IS ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS
A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WITH NO ONE ELSE IN THE
PORT CARE ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
TOP POSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NO MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WATER PLEASE GIVE ANYONE
OPPOSED SB EIGHTY ONE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'D
LIKE TO HAVE MY- NAME WITHDRAWN
I WAS ATTEMPTING TO BE IN
SUPPORT. WHAT IS YOUR- THE-
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MUST WE HAVE
NO ONE IN HOUSTON- ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHTY ONE AND SEEING NO
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHTY
ONE. MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
MOVING S. B. TWO NINETY. ONE
DENSITY BONUS LAW SENATOR
SKINNER'S WAY PRESENTATION AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. TWO
NINETY THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO NINETY WATER PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINETY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU-WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY ONE PERSON IN Q. ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- WILLIAM UNPREPARED
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A COUPLE
CLIENTS ON SB TWO NINETY-
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY-
CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND THE HOME
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AT THE PORT OF SB
TWO NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT-
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THIS
COMPANY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MINOR PLEASE KEEP UP THE
OPPOSITION PRESS B. TO NINETY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE PERSON IN Q. ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BOKAN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE PERSON WHO
JUST CHEWED UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WITH AN OPERATOR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WILL NOT
OPEN LINE ONE HUNDRED. ONE ONE
HUNDRED. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBERS IT'S JENNIFER KENNEDY
AN ATTORNEY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON MY OWN
BEHALF IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
NINETY. NEXT CALL MY NUMBER ONE
ELEVEN ONE ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOU MY NAME IS LESLIE
AND I. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
HER. ALL RIGHT HAVE IN FRONT OF
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION IN SB TWO NINETEEN
SEEING NO HANDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB TWO NINETY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIES SB THREE
NINETY EIGHT. ALSO BY SENATOR
SKINNER ON CANNABIS LICENSING.
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
AND THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTERS OF
THIS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. C.
KNOWN IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
SING NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- OUR MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
PEOPLE IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BY NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WESTERN MEMBERS I'M THE
BEST I MEET AS ON BEHALF OF
CRESCO LABS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO
HAVE- PARTICIPANTS CURRENTLY
WITH OPERATORS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE BACK TO OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE OH FIVE I WANNA
FIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS GEORGE MILLER ON
BEHALF OF WEEDMAPS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE SIXTEEN ONE ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF THE
CONVECTION IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK AT THE PORT
OF SP THREE NINETY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE MOVED
OPPOSITION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY
REPORTED TWO OH THREE THAT HAVE
BEEN AROUND TWENTY FORTY.
FIGHTER PLEASE PLEASE KEEP UP
THE OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
NINETY EIGHT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINE
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE NINE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SP THREE NINETY
EIGHT AND SEEING NO CALL NONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES WITH
QUESTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THREE NINETY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO DOCTOR PAN
WAS. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX. SIX BILLS BEFORE US TODAY.
THEY'RE ALL SUSPENSE BUT TO ME
THEY'RE ALL SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES. WILL MOVE ON SB
SEVENTEEN ON OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY- THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF AN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BETTER
POLICE QUEUE UP THE SUPPORT FOR
SB SEVENTEEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF SB SEVENTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. ONE NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ONE MOUNTAIN BERG- HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL INTO PARK
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TURN NUMBERS MADELINE COOPER
FROM NIELSEN ROCKSTAR ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REMEMBER
KERN COUNTY CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN COURT OKAY SB
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A. B. SANTOS ON BEHALF OF S. E.
I. U. CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. I
NEEDED TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GENEROUSLY HAVE HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. FOR ONE
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEANWHILE I'M VERY WELL FROM
THE SUMMER YOU CAN CALIFORNIA
AYE OPPOSED. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS A- HE ENTERED LEBANON
COURT. LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BREMBO CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. ONE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DEGREE CLAIM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THE ONE MONOIDS.
VETERANS WALKING TALK NUMBER IN
SUPPORT. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. APOLOGY WOMAN
VERY AGAIN ALSO WITH NAY ROB
PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I NEED FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KATHY BEEN
OFTEN AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THE
AT THE DEMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN THE STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. COLIN WELLS US ARMY
INFANTRY VETERAN FOUNDER OF
VETERANS WALKING TALKING
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE PERSONAL DISPUTE AT
THE CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WHEN I OPEN
UP MY NUMBER ONE TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RON RAPP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
POLICE HAVE GREAT SERVICE
CONNECTED VETERAN MEMBER
VETERANS WALKING TOWARD THEM IN
SUPPORT. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE DO HAVE ONE A PERSON ACCUSED
UP. NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JAMES WOOD
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU. IN LINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I JUST
SPOKE ABOUT A LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. NEVER MIND
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
IF NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORTER.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES OPPOSED. LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE ONE PERSON IN THIS ROOM
WHO WANTS TO. LOWS SB SEVENTEEN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION-
JOSH RECALLING FROM ROSEVILLE
AND I OPPOSE SB SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE IF
YOU COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE ON
THE LINE OPPOSED SB SEVENTEEN
NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO ACTIVE TIME. ONE ONE
HUNDRED AS WE WILL DISCUSS WITH
ZERO ONE ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
LESLIE ONE UMBRELLA AND AYE
OPPOSED. ONE ONE HUNDRED- LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS JENNIFER KENNEDY
ATTORNEY SPEAKING PERSONALLY
AYE OPPOSED. SEVENTEEN ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
NINETEEN GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANDREA
HEDSTROM AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND TELL THE CHILDREN THAT
WERE KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL WITH
SB TWO SEVEN SIX AND THAT IS
THE REAL HEALTH EMERGENCY AYE
OPPOSED SB SEVENTEEN. V. FOUR
POINT FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIND FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IF YOUR MIND IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. TO
RESPOND TO OPEN MY NUMBER ONE
OH SEVEN. SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS STEPHANIE
SILVA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NINE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE ONE A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JEFF TECLADO AND AYE
OPPOSED SB. SEVENTEEN FIND ONE-
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS STACY FELLOWS
SACRAMENTO STUDENTS THEN IT
SHOULD BE VERY TELLING TO
EVERYBODY WHO CALLED IN AND
SUPPORTS DOCTOR CAN BUILD ALL
SPECIAL INTERESTS. I AM A
GRASSROOTS INDIVIDUAL LIFE ONE
FITNESS CENTER AND I ADAMANTLY
OPPOSE THE RECREATING POLITICS
HE STRAINED INTER TWINE INTO
OUR COMMUNITY. SB SEVENTEEN
NOTRE. RAIDER PLEADING GUILTY.
MODERATOR MODERATOR YEAH WE'RE
IN YES WE'RE IN THE ME TOO
SECTION WHICH IS NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION SO
PLEASE FOLLOW MY CUES. YES SIR
THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME. ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION IN YOUR ORGANIZATION.
HI THIS IS LIBERTY I AM AN
ABSOLUTE OPPOSITION. BOB THIS
BILL. ONE ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LESLIE BONTA AND I TO- DISAGREE
AND OPPOSE ANYTHING THAT
HAPPENS TO PEOPLE TO PREVENT
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY TONY ROAD
BALLOTS WITH CAPITOL RESEARCH
INTERFERE IN OPPOSITION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVENTEEN YOUR LIGHT THREE FIVE
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME MODERATOR
HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE ACUTA. ONE
PERSONS ARE ACTUALLY NOW THREE
PEOPLE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME. ONE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
BRITNEY SHE AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION. ONE ONE A ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JEFF BAKER
KALEIDO RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED BILL SB
SEVENTEEN. NINE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DARLENE BUNGALOWS
WAS PRESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT
STILL. WE HAVE ONE MORE TERM MY
ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN I GET IT FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. ARABI HAVE
UNLIMITED CHEWED UP. WE TAKE
THIS LAST WINTER- HAVE. NINE
ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JESSICA COLLADO REDNECK OF
STANDING UP COUNTY AYE OPPOSED
SB SEVENTEEN. ALL RIGHT AND THE
VOLUME IS DROPPED OFF FOR LIKE
THE LAST FIVE FOLKS IF WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE CLEAR THAT ISSUE
UP. HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTEEN
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVENTEEN. GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AS BEFORE TO-
DR PANA PERSONAL SERVICE
CONTRACTS. FATHER'S WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. SAYING NOBODY IN
ROOM. FORTY TWO- THREE. IN
OPPOSITION S. B. FOR TWO TO SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE IF THE QUEUE UP ANYONE
ON THE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWO TWO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
UP PART OF SB FOUR TWO TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO APPETITE.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q.
ONE ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN.IN THE VOLUME IS STILL
RELATIVELY LOW VERSUS THE WAY
WE STARTED. I OPPOSE THEM.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN. GEORGE OSBORNE
REPRESENTING THE UNION OF THE-
ERIC IN POSITIONS AND TESTED IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWO TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWO TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT THERE. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE COMPOSITION OF SB
FOUR TWO TWO THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP UP THE
OPPOSITION S. B. FOUR TWO TWO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR TWO TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
TRAFFICCOM FROM ROSEVILLE I
OPPOSE S. B. FOUR TWO TWO. IS
THAT YOU ONE ONE TWENTY. IN
THIS. ONE ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIRTEEN
BUNGALOWS RESIDENTS DIEGO
COUNTY I DON'T. NINE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BRITNEY SHE
N. WITH INDEPENDENT LABOR
ALLIANCE. REPRESENTING THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
IMPACTED BY A. B. FIVE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. BLIND
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LET'S MOVE ON AND FIND OUT OF A
STATE COUNTY AND AGAIN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL SENATOR COTTON HE
THANK YOU LINE ONE THIRTEEN.
ONE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN I GET IT FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
OF FOUR TWO TWO THANK YOU. ONE
ONE A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHECK THE COLOR DON'T PANIC-
COUNTY HELLO SB. FORTY TWO.
BLOOD ONE- TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES STACEY FELLOWS WITH CITY OF
SACRAMENTO DON'T OPPOSE SB.
FOUR TWO TWO. NEVER MIND IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR TWO TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO LACK OF TIME. ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR MIND IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. I OPPOSE
BILL FOR YOU. TO ONE ONE A ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TRAFFIC HAD
QUITE OF BENDIGO COUNTY AYE
OPPOSED AT THE. FORTY TWO. LINE
ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SONOMA SPENDING GO COUNTY
I APPROVED IF PEOPLE. TWENTY
TWO. AND LINE ONE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CRISTINA
HERRERA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB. FOUR TWO TWO. MIGHT WANNA
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BERNIE I
OPPOSE AT LEAST. FORTY TWO. WE
DO HAVE ONE MORNING CUTER
CALLING WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WITH ALKALINE ONE
FORTY ONE. BY ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
LESLIE SENATORS THAT CANYON I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. HI NINE ONE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. B.
CZECHO KALEIDO RESIDENT INDIGO
AYE OPPOSED SB FORTY TWO. AND
WE HAVE NOT ENOUGH COMPUTER ALL
RIGHT SIR WERE YOU GOING TO
TESTIFY ON THIS ONE. DID YOU.
NO YOU'RE GOOD OKAY. HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AS
BEFORE TO AND EEING NO HANDS
GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FOUR TWO TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO S. B. FOR
SIXTY ALSO BY DR PAN A LONG
TERM HEALTH FACILITIES- THE
GARBAGE WAY PRESENTATIONS
DISPENSED CANDIDATE. THERE ARE
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE SOMEONE IS
MOVING OVER TO THE MICROPHONE
ARE YOU STILL. ALL RIGHT THERE
IS. NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
MODERATES COULD QUEUE UP THE
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR SIXTY NOW
IS THE OPPORTUNITY. YES SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PORT OF SB
FOUR SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO ACTIVE TIME. LINE ONE
TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI I'M ACTUALLY CALLING TO
ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE. SIXTY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN SUPPORT THERE. AREN'T
MOVING IN OPPOSITION OF US
BEFORE SIXTY THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY UP YES
WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY COMING UP
TO OPPOSE THIS BEFORE SIXTY.
MINUTES JOSHUA COLEMAN FROM
ROSEVILLE AND I OPPOSE SB FOUR
SIXTY. NINE THANK SEARCHING NO
ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM SING
KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE SKIP ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED US
BEFORE SIXTEEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU SPEAK IT IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FOUR SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ONE OH
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THE
TEAMS LIKE THE PERFECT ATTACK
ON NURSING HOMES WHEN WHAT WE
NEED IS YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IN ADDITION. YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. INDIVIDUAL
ORGANIZATION COMMONSENSE
SACRAMENTO WICKS. ONE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
BILLION THINKING IN OPPOSITION.
ONE ONE A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND WHAT I WANT I WANT OPEN.
JESSICA COLLADO RESNET AND
FINAGLE I OPPOSE SB. FOUR
SIXTEEN. ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BLUEBERRY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OPPOSE THE
BILL. ONE ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY BATMAN AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL. ONE ONE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LEPLEY BY COUNTY. ONE ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
MEAN BOND LISTEN YOU'LL COUNTY
AYE OPPOSED BILL. RIGHT ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI RIVERSIDE COUNTY I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. ONE ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GENERAL
MOTORS SAN DIEGO COUNTY I
OPPOSE IF PEOPLE SIXTEEN. ONE
ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KAREN GADDIS FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY I CALL IN ASPEN IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR SIXTY
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER
KENNEDY L. A. COUNTY OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION. WHITE WON FOURTY
THICK FELINE OPEN. UNDER
HEDSTROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY
REPRESENTING FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND HEALTHY CHILDREN WHO
HAVE NO VOICE. AMERONGEN JAIL
AYE OPPOSED PLEASE THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB FOUR
SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GOOD
HELLO FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
I HAVE. ONE ONE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LESLIE BONTA AND
I WOULD LIKE PROPOSALS BILL.
ONE ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JENNIFER FOUND BOTH FROM
OVERSIGHT COUNTY I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP. FOUR
SIXTY. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT HAVEN'T TAKEN THE SPORT
IN OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY
SYNCING NO HANDS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS BEFORE SIXTY. TO
GO TO SUSPENSE BILLION SB FIVE
TENS BY DOCTOR PAN ON HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE CODE NINETEEN
COST SHARING. OF THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION THIS IS AN
EMERGENCY ITEM THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT. ISSUE
PLEASE QUEUE OF ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE TEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO THINK OF THE
QUARTER SB TEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN SUPPORT
TO OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO BROWN
BOTH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION MARTIN THANK DOCTOR
CAN'T FORGET LEADERS. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MATA
GOT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS ONE OF THE FOLLOWING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES OF THE COURT THANK
YOU. AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PORT OF SB
FIVE TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. JEAN AUTHORS CAN
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
THERE. ALL RIGHT WELL NOW MOVE
ON OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TEN WE
HAVE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE A GENTLEMAN
HERE PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION. POSSIBLE COLEMAN
FROM ROSELLE I OPPOSE SB FIVE
TEN THANK YOU SIR WILL MOVE ON
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO
ONE THERE. BINDERY PLEASE QUEUE
UP THE OPPOSITION SB FIVE CENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
APPOINT USER WE'RE GOING ON MY
NUMBER ONE TENURE LINE IS OPEN.
YOU CAN'T SPEAKING IN OPPOSITE
25% ONE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SACRAMENTO COUNTY THE
PAM BELONGS IN JAIL. MY NUMBER
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REMOVE THE CUSTOM Q. ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BASTON. ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT NO RESPONSIBLE BONTA
ON ABOUT FIFTY SEVEN LINE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CELEBRITY SACRAMENTO COUNTY
POSTED BILL. ONE ONE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JUST
FACT I RIGHT BACK OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY I OPPOSE SB FIVE PLAN.
REMEMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHERYL MOSER
BENDIGO COUNTY AYE OPPOSED SB
FIVE TUNE. ONE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER FOUND
OUT RIVERSIDE COUNTY OPPOSE SB.
FIVE TEN. ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KALING GADDIS
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
OPPOSE SB FIVE TEN THANK YOU.
ONE ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I DON'T COUNTY CHRIS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. FIVE TEN FORTY ONE.
ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GIVEN HELLO SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ONE ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JENNIFER KENNEDY L. A. COUNTY
APPROVED SB FIVE CAN. ONE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JEFF
LEVINE A LOT OF RESPECT COUNTY
I STRONGLY OPPOSE OF CELL. ONE
OF SEVEN YEAR LINED OPEN. ONE
ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WITH THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY
LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY NAME IS
SHANNON HEIL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. AND AT THAT
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
FUTURE ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE TENDENCY NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE TEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. LIVING ON
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT HI DOCTOR
PAN ON SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT. EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WILL TAKE SUPPORT
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO MAN
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR PLEASE COME TO
SUPPORT FOR SB. FIVE NINE
EIGHT. AT THIS TIME. S. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU TO SPEAK
UP. SB NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE WANTED. ONE
EIGHTY OR IS OPEN. YOUR CARE
MEMBERS MONICA AND BE HAPPY OF
IBM LOW. TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN
SUPPORT. AND AS EVERYBODY
BECAUSE THE PORT OF SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ZERO
AT THE TIME. BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ELSE APART. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT. WE HAVE ONE
PERSON IN THIS ROOM GO AHEAD
SIR. OPTIONAL COLEMAN FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE S. B. FIVE NINE EIGHT.
ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE HERE
SIGNALING A ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MOVING TO THE PHONE LINE- ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT. PLEASE GIVE THEM UP NOW.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AT PETE B. S. B. FIVE NINETY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TEN Q. OPEN MY NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THIS IS LIBERTY FROM SACRAMENTO
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE END
DIGGING IN OPPOSITION. ONE ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KALING GET S. SACRAMENTO COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE NINE
EIGHT THANK YOU. ONE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DARLENE BUT
BALANCING DEAL COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL F. B. FIVE
NINETY. ONE ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT I'M
FOREVER RESPECT COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE NINE
AND- ONE ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BALAMAND L. A.
COUNTY I OPPOSE SB AB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT. ONE ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. UNDER THEIR
HEADS FROM SACRAMENTOCOUNTY I
OPPOSE EVERYTHING ABOUT DICK
PAN THANK YOU LINE ONE L. SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOME
INTERNATIONAL COUNTY- EARLIER I
WAS TRYING TO THINK MY
OPPOSITION. TO AT. FOR AND-
THIS IS FIVE NINE EIGHT THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER KENNEDY
L. A. COUNTY AYE OPPOSED SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT. NINE ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BENNIFER FRANKEL RIVERSIDE
COUNTY OPPOSED FIFTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT. ONE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY I
OPPOSE SB FIVE NINETY. ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS SHANNON HEIL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS CHRISTINE AND I OPPOSE SB.
FIVE NINETY. ONE OR TWO IN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
STACY PASCAL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THIRTY ONE OFTEN
OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE NINE
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THE TIME. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHAPTER TECLADO
RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE AT THE FIVE NINETY.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO
HAVE A MY PARTICIPANT THAT'S
WITH AN OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE NINE ONE SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHRISTINE RUSSIAN FINANCIAL
COUNTY I OPPOSE BILL FIVE
NINETY EIGHT. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE AND USER ALL
RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES FOR SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHTEEN NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT SO TO SUSPEND.
MOVING ON SB SEVEN FORTY TWO DR
PANA VACCINATION SITES UNLAWFUL
PHYSICAL OBSTRUCTIONS. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANADA DOCTORS WAY
PRESENTATION AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES OF TOTAL TIME. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TEST FINDING
MUCH TESTIFIED MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS THE NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. WE WILL ALSO
LIMIT THE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
FOR TWELVE TO TWELVE MINUTES
FOR EACH SIDE. AND FOR A TOTAL
OF FIFTEEN MINUTES AND AS A
REMINDER ALL WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE BILL
WE'RE NOT GOING TO USE THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR POLITICAL
STATEMENTS. OR TO REDO GET
LITIGATE THE MERITS OF THE BILL
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE SO
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE TO
GENERAL PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE DO NOT
HAVE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND SO WE WILL GO TO
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S NO
ONE HERE. IN TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE OF ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FORTY TWO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WERE TO THINK OF THE PORT OF SB
SEVEN FOUR TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
SUPPORTER. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION WE
HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION YOUR TOTAL TIME IS
THREE MINUTES. WE HAVE SHANNON
HEIL IN ORANGE CT. I HOPE I
PRONOUNCE THE NAMES CORRECTLY.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
COALITION AND AGAIN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE ARE YOU ARE.
I'M ORRIN HEATLEY ALL RIGHT
HERE ORANGE SO I HAVE SHARON
FIRSTLY SHE ONLINE. ALL RIGHTY
SHARON HERE MODERATOR SHANNON
SHE'S MINAJ SHARE SHANNON. IF
NOT WE'LL GO TO LIKE DON'T YOU
DON'T SEE HER OR HEAR HER I
DON'T ALIGN ALL RIGHT WE WILL
GO TO MISTER KEATING WHO WE
WILL START THE CLOCK RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THAT MY NAME IS
WARREN HE LEE ON THE LEE
PROPONENT FOR THE RECALL GAVIN
TWENTY TWENTY DOT COM TEAM I
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL- IT DOES HAVE A NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE PUBLIC.
YOU'RE IMPOSING A FINE OF A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PLUS THE
THREAT OF JAIL TIME WHICH WILL
HELP YOU PLAN YOUR MASCOT THANK
WHICH WILL HAVE NEGATIVE
NEGATIVE. IMPACTS I NATURALLY
ON THE STATE. AND- CAN I HAVE
SOME MY TIME BACK FOR THAT I'LL
GIVE YOU TEN SECONDS OKAY AND-
IF YOU KNOWS THAT IMPOSING. A
FINE JAIL TIME- THE COURT THE
COURT COSTS YOUR OWN BILL SAYS
IT COSTS ABOUT. EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS. EIGHT HOUR DAY TO RUN
A COURT ROOM WHICH IS FINANCIAL
A FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THE
SYSTEM. ADDITIONAL THAT DOESN'T
EXIST ALREADY AND IN- IN
RESTRICTING OF PEOPLE'S FIRST
AMENDMENT RGHTS PEOPLE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO. MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
COMMUNICATE WITH ONE ANOTHER IN
A PUBLIC PLACE. AND ANYBODY
THAT VOTES IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL IS VOTING TO RESTRICT
PEOPLE'S FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND
FREEDOM OF ASSEMBLY AND FREEDOM
OF MOVEMENT. SO AGAIN I OBJECT
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR IS
MS SHANNON HEIL WITH US EITHER
VIRTUALLY. OR OTHERWISE.
MODERATOR I DO NOT THAT SHE'S
JOINTER ALL RIGHT YEAH I. THIS
YEAR BUTCHER'S POST SHE WAS TO
BE IN PRAYER I AM. YEAH ON THE
PHONE OR- BOB GIVE ONE MORE
OPPORTUNITY THE MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD FIND SHANNON HEIL.
THE PILOT HERE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO OPEN UP
YOUR LINE. WHAT ECONOMIC HIGH
WITH YOUR ON THE LINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO OPEN UP YOUR
LINE. BUT I WAS FINE YES MY
LINE ALL RIGHT MISSILE THAT YOU
HAVE A MINUTE AND FIFTEEN
SECONDS LEFT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO I AM THE COUNTY RECALL
I'M HERE TODAY TO OPPOSE SB
SEVEN FOUR TO THE DIRECT
INFRINGEMENT ON THE RIGHTS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS CITIZENS WHEN
YOU SILENCE THE GROUP OF PEOPLE
OF WHICH YOU DO NOT AGREE WITH
YOUR SILENCING OF ALL. TODAY
YOU'RE TRYING TO PASS A BILL
WHICH STOP PEOPLE FROM CATHOLIC
PROTECTING TOMORROW HE WILL GO
AFTER ANOTHER MINUTE. IF PEOPLE
FEEL SOMETHING ISN'T BEING
CORRECTLY REPRESENTED IN THE
PUBLIC. IT IS OUR RIGHT TO
PEACEFULLY PROTEST. WE ALREADY
HAVE LAWS PUT IN PLACE TO STOP
APPROACH HAVE BEEN PICKETING
WILL THE COMING. BATTLE THERE
CALL THE POLICE THIS IS THE
FIRST YEAR AND EIGHTY SEVEN
IT'LL YOU THINK OUT YOUR
CRIMINAL I'VE GROUP OF PEOPLE
PROTESTERS PASSING ON
INFORMATION ON THE TOPIC THEY
BELIEVE IS BEING MISREPRESENTED
TO THE PUBLIC. AT THE END
DEFINITELY A CONTROVERSIAL
SUBJECT BUT IT IS NOT A REASON
WHY PEOPLE SHOULD LOSE THEIR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT. SB SEVEN
FORTY WITH HEARING AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BELIEVE THERE ARE STILL
MORE THAN A FEW GREAT BUTTER IN
OFFICE WOULD STILL PROTECT THE
RIGHTS. OF THEIR PEOPLE BUT
WHAT TIME IS THE INFORMATION IF
THE PRODUCT IS COMPLETELY SAFE
AND SOUND WORTHWHILE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IF THE
FURTHER FOLKS COULD CONFINE
THEIR NAY TO THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION. WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND PLEASE.
COME ON UP. NAY ORGANIZED AND
I'M GOING TO SEE THE CLOCK
RIGHT NOW GO MY NAME IS COLEMAN-
FROM ROSEVILLE I AM THE CO
FOUNDER OF V. IS FOR VACCINE
IT'S THE LARGEST VACCINE RISK
PUBLIC EDUCATION GROUP IN BOTH
CALIFORNIA AND THIS COUNTRY
AND- THIS IS ACTUALLY SILENCE
OVER HERE POSITION AXING RISKS
WILL WE'RE NOT TAKING ANYMORE
TESTAMENT ISSUE BY ISSUE I VERY
MUCH OPPOSE THIS COMMUNIST
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION AND
LIVE IT UP FOR ALL OF THE
MICROSOFT CO FOUNDER VIA THE
PREVIOUS FOR VACCINE AS WELL
AND JUST LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT PUBLICLY CONFIRMED
THAT THE CLAIMS HOUSTON WE'RE
ONLY TAKING YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
AND LIMIT FIRST MONDAY. NIGHTS
ARE 1100% FALSE THE
JUSTIFICATION THANK YOU. ARE
1100% FALSE WE WILL NOW GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR AGAIN
AND FOR EVERYBODY THERE
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU DON'T STICK
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WE WILL CUT YOU OFF
SO THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
PLEASE USE IT BECAUSE WERE
PROVIDING IT FOR YOU. YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION MODERATOR OPPOSITION.
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB FORTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE HAD IN Q. ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PREVENTING FROM SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE FIFTY SEVEN FORTY CARE
AND ALSO CAN MAKE. ONE ONE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THE WHITE ONE- TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
STACEY FELLOW LIFELONG FOR THE
SENATE SACRAMENTO COMMONSENSE.
AYE OPPOSED. ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSE OPEN MY NUMBER ONE TEN
ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
I MEAN I HAVE A POINT OF ORDER
DOES NOT- THIS PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. MY NAME OF BRITNEY
SHE ONLINE REPRESENTING THE
PEOPLE WHO LOVE THE
CONSTITUTION AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. ONE ONE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THE CONVENTION
CENTER AND I'M A CO. WHITE ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE BALANCE A LOT FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I AM A MOTHER
OF A VACCINE INJURED CHILD I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
WISH I KNEW THANK YOU. ONE ONE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHERYL MOSER FANDANGO COUNTY
REPRESENTING U. S. CONSTITUTION
AYE OPPOSED SB SEVEN FOURTEEN.
BY ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SHE'S AND HOWLS INDIGO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. LINE ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TURNING BLOOD RED LOS
INYO COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. ONE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
ADRIAN HALF OF PLASTER COUNTY
MOTHER OF A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
SEVEN FOUR TWO WHICH PROHIBITS
OUR RIGHT TO ASSEMBLE. ONE ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT CAN BE ABOUT BATMAN L. A.
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
SEVEN FOUR TWO. ONE ONE SIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT NO RESPONSE WILL OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JENNIFER FRANCO
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SEVEN FORTY TWO IS BEING
UNLAWFUL. NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE BERLIN FROM
THE RIGHT LIGHT LEAGUE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS COURTNEY TAYLOR I'M
FROM HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND I'M
GOING TO OPPOSE SB. SEVEN FOUR
TWO. ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SEPECAT KALEIDO
RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE AT THE SEVEN FOUR
KILL. ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MICHAEL THE
STOCK. ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER KENNEDY
L. A. COUNTY I VIGOROUSLY
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FORTY TWO.
MCCARTY APREHEND THEM ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SANTANA AND
I'M FROM ANY ACCOUNTING AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER EVAN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
REPRESENT THE MILLIONS THAT
WERE NOT GIVEN PROPER INFORMED
CONSENT AND I APPROVE THIS BILL.
ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO
USE MODERN I OPPOSE AT. SEVEN
FORTY TWO. ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HOW MANY MORE
MODERATE SIXTY THREE- WE HAVE
FOREIGN Q. SIR THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME ONE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE BONTA ONE NUMBER
ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MODERN
MODERATOR- KILLING GET ANSWERS
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN FOUR TWO THANK YOU
AGAIN. ONE OH TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS MAN A
PASCAL. AYE OPPOSED SB SEVEN
FOUR TWO. BUT. ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE PEOPLE
WILL NOT PUT UP WITH A- ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL I OPPOSE THIS BILL. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU SIR
ALL RIGHT HAVING PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION INCLUDING TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES FOR THE
OPPOSITION SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO FOR THE TWO SUSPECTS.
FOR THE NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
IS S. B. TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR
GLAZERS TO CREATE A SPECIALIZED
LICENSE PLATES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS THIS ITEM IS
ALSO A SINCE RENTS CANDID. AND
MISTER GLAZER HAS WAY
PRESENTATION- LET'S MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC THIS MONEY ANYWAY ONE. I
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY ONE
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY ON
A TELECONFERENCE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY ONE.
AND- CALL THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUALLY. YES SIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK OF THE PORT OF SB TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD BECAUSE THE PORT OF SB
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL OPEN MY
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE RAIN BY SEN.
VETERAN AND MEMBER OF VETERANS
WALK AND TALK IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT ANYONE ELSE MY
APOLOGIES FIFTY ONE OF WHICH IS
BECAUSE SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THE TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE
OF IMPORT. ARE HAVING HER FROM
SUPPORT ASSISTANCE TO THE
OPPOSITION- IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE IN ROOM. FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWENTY ONE LOOKING. AT THE-
THERE'S NO WITNESSES IN ROOM.
TWENTY FOURTEEN OPPOSITION SO
MODERATE- WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT WITNESSES WOULDN'T
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWENTY ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION THERE ARE
CURRENTLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL THE WITNESSES THE
SPRING AFFECT THE COMMITTEE I
SEE NO. HANDS UP BY MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWENTY ONE WILL MOVE DISPENSED
CONDER. LET'S MOVE TO THE-
CENTER GLAZERS NEXT BILL S. B.
FIVE NINE THREE WHICH IS NOT
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
AUDIT REQUIREMENTS. THIS ITEM
IS THE SUSPENSE CANDID MIST
MISTER GLAZER HAS WAY
PRESENTATION. SO LET'S MOVE
RIGHT ON TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINE THREE.
I DON'T SEE ANY THEN SEE.
BRITAIN THAT HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO
SATISFY. SO MODERATOR WONDERED
CHU PROMPT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN TELECONFERENCE LINE.
SUPPORT SB. FIVE NINE THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD THINK OF THE PORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE NINE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD BE
GIVEN PORT OF SB FIVE NINE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I DO NOT OF. OUR
AT THIS FALL THE SAME PROCESS
IS HERE TO SEE IF WE CAN HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION OTHER ANY
WITNESSES. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ONE TESTIFYING ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SEEING NONE. I
SEE NO ARE PERSONS IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION OF
US BEEF FIVE NINE THREE
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROP
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE NINE THREE. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ABOUT SB FIVE NINE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND YOU'RE A LACK OF
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
PERSON IN OPPOSITION LIKE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BRAMBELL SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT UP TO ONE QUEUE
UP THERE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. BY
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO. NO COMMENT FROM ONE TWENTY
SIX SO WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
TO ALL THE WITNESSES IS
PERFECTLY COMMITTEE I SEE NO
HANDS UP BY MY COLLEAGUES TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE NINE THREE.
DISPENSED CALENDAR NEXT WE
HAVE. SB SIX SEED. SIX BY
CENTER GLACIER WHICH IS THE
CAMPAIGN DISCLOSURE LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES THIS ITEM
IS A SUSPENSE CAN THAT AN THE
CENTER HAS WAY PRESENTATION SO
LET'S MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ASK NO ONE HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. TESTIFYING
SUPPORT SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN IN ROOM FOR A TWENTY
FORTY TO TESTIFY SO MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT WITNESSES TESTED
WE NEED TO TESTIFY IN THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE SUPPORT OF
SB. SIX EIGHT SIX BY GLAZER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PORT OF SB
SIX EIGHT SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE PERSON IN
CUBA CALLING WITH EVERYONE ON
THE PLANET. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ALL THE LIGHT OF WHAT
AFFECTS YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ON
BEHALF OF THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX EIGHT SIX. OKAY WITH
THAT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT I
APOLOGIZE WE DID HAVE ONE THAT
JUST POPPED UP. THE COURT WITH
AN OPERATOR. AND THEY REMOVED
THOUSAND HERE NO ONE OF IMPORT.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE HERE FOR
FULL THE SAME PROCESS INVOLVED
HERE FROM THE OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
SUPPORT OF OR IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. SIX EIGHT SIXTEEN NINE. I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM UP. FOR TWO. TWO ZERO FOUR
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. SIX
EIGHT SIX MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE PROP WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX EIGHT SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX EIGHT
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX EIGHT SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ALL FOR
ALL THE WITNESSES A SPRING FED
COMMITTEE SING NO HAN SO-
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX EIGHT
SIX WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE
ACCOUNT UNDER. NEXT UP IS S. B.
799% OR GLAZER WHICH IS THE OFF
HIGHWAY. VEHICLE RECREATION
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICLE
RECREATION AREA ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSION THIS. SENATOR HAS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS ITEM IS ALSO
A MEMBER OF. A CANDIDATE FOR
THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR SO LET'S
MOVE TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY I
DO NOT SEE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IN SUPPORT
OF. SB SEVEN NINE NINE NOR DO I
SEE YOU ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY AND SUPPORTS OF
MODERATE PLEASE PROP WITNESSES
WILLING TO TESTIFY. ON A
TELECONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN NINE NINE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK OF THE PORT OF SB SEVEN
NINE NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF
THE PORT OF S. B. SEVEN NINE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT SUPPORT OKAY LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS MOVED
HERE FROM THE OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. IN TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN NINE
NINE SEEING NONE I SEE NO
WITNESSES AND- FOR. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN NINE NINE SEVEN
HUNDRED PLEASE. PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAY INTENSIFIED
OPPOSITION UP SB SEVEN NINE
NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN NINE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
NINE NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND I SHOW NO ONE
OPPOSITION- THANK YOU LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE- TO THE
DAIS- I'M HEARING ANY WITNESSES
TO SUPPORT WE HAVE. SAYS FORMER
SECRETARY LETTER TO YOUR
RECOGNIZE. I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY QUICKLY ON THIS BILL ON THE
FISCAL MERITS THAT FOUR YEARS
OF THIS AUTHOR ANOTHER PEOPLE
HAVE TRIED TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO RESOLVE THIS LONG STANDING
DISPUTE. AND THE ONLY WAY TO DO
WHAT IS WITH CASH TO BUY OUT
THE OFF ROAD VEHICLE FUNDED
THIS BILL FINALLY DOES IT SO IF
THIS MATTER IS TO EVER BE
RESOLVED EVEN THOUGH I THINK
IT'S A NINE MILLION DOLLAR COST
TO THE GENERAL FUND. THIS IS
THE WAY TO DO IT SO ON THE
FISCAL MERITS I JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN NINE NINE
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE CALENDAR
LET'S MOVE TO CENTER COURT SHE
SEES- BILLS HE HAS SB THIRTY
TWO. WHICH IS ON ENERGY GENERAL
PLAN BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS AN ITEM.
UP ALSO CANADA FOR SUSPENSE IN.
A CENTER CORTESE AS WE
PRESENTATION SO LET'S MOVE TO
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTY TWO I SEE
NO BORN HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE TO TESTIFY. NOR DO I SEE
WITNESSES IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY TWO SOME MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORT
SB THIRTY TWO BY CORTES E.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PART OF SB
THIRTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I NUMBER SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
CHRIS STOCKWELL DAHLE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA AND
DEMOCRATS IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHECKS FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU. AND WE DO HAVE ONE ONE
CUTER CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT LINE TO
ONCE AGAIN IF CONVICTED BECAUSE
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE ONE OH FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHEN ONE OF FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOUR LINE IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
ONCE AGAIN ONE OF FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT THE RESPONSE AMONG
ALL FOR ALL OVER THE LINE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT HI.
MOSTLY HEARING FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS THIS FALL THE SAME
PROCESS TO HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
PRESENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. BY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY TO SING
NINE I SEE NO. WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION
THIRTY TWO MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT WITNESSES WE INTENSIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY TWO.
TWENTY AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO PICK IT UP INITIATIVE
SB THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q. ONE
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU JENNIFER
KENNEDY L. A. COUNTY AYE
OPPOSED SB. THIRTY TWO. AND ONE
OF THE PREFERRED EXPERT
TYPICALLY WITH AN OPERATOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. ON ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU PRETTY
GOOD ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS ARE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE OPPOSITION. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE WITNESSES SPRING BACK
TO TWENTY SEEING NO HANDS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTY WAS
MOVED TO DISPENSED CALENDARS
NEXT CENTER CORTES HE HAS. SB
SIX NINE THREE WHICH IS LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY-
PLAN STATE PRIORITIES IN LEAST
RESTRICTIVE- ENVIRONMENT. THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE AND
HE IS WAY PRESENTATION SO LET'S
MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IS
THERE ANY ONE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. AND
SUPPORTIVE SB SIX. SIX NINE TWO
SEEING NONE I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT OF- ESPYS SIX NINE TWO
SOME MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES WAITING. TESTIFYING
TELECONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORT
SB. SIX NINE TWO BY CORTESE.
YES SIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO THINK OF THE PORT
OF SB SIX NINE TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
ONE IN Q. ONE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BIRCH GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IMPORT. ONE ONE OF
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE OF
MY IN. THE FEDERAL COALITION.
THE DISABILITY PICKING ON THE
POP OF THE COLLECTIVE OF BJP
ALCOTT AND BREAK OUT THE PARENT
SACRAMENTO THE U. S. B.
BENCHMARK U. S. B. ON SATURDAY.
THE INCLUDING THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO DID WHAT THE COURT
BROUGH THE REPORT OF. THE
MORGAN. WELL. GUARANTY
CALIFORNIA. HM REPORT IN ONLY
ABOUT NOT BATTLE THE BARRIERS
REGION. AND LATER GENTLEMEN
AFTER MY IF YOU WOULD SPEAK AT
THE OF SB SIX NINE TO YOU MAY
PRESS ZERO ACCESS TO. AND I
DON'T KNOW ONE OF THE PORTS ARE
CURRENT HAVING HER FROM THE
SUPPORTERS LET'S FALL THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION OF ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN. ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE IN OPPOSITION OF SB. SIX
NINETY- SEEING NINE SEEING KNOW
WHAT THIS IS A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE WING PLEASE.
PROP WITNESSES WAITING SAYS
FIND A POSITION OF S. B. SIX
NINE. TWO AND CALL THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUALLY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX NINE
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE OPPOSITION PLAYER
OKAY LET'S BRING UP. BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO HAN
SUPERMARKETS COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX NINETY WILL BE
MOVED TO SUSPENSE COUNTERS THAT
WE HAVE CENTER- BURKE WHO HAS
FIVE BILLS. SB THIRTY FOUR
WHICH IS ADDRESSES LIBRARIES
AND STUDENT SUCCESS CARDS ISN'T
URGENCY MATTER IT DOES ALSO IN
FACT SUSPENSE CAN DIDN'T CENTER
NUMBER BECAUSE WAY PRESENTATION
SO LET'S GO TO. THE PUBLIC
HEARING IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
FOUR. I SEE NO WITNESSES I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TESTS FIND SUPPORTS A
MODERATE PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES WAITING TESTIFIED A
TELECONFERENCE LINE IN SUPPORTOF SB. THIRTY FOUR AND CALL
THEM INDIVIDUALLY. YES BUT AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF REPORTS OF SB THIRTY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND WE
SHOULD KNOW WHAT IT SUPPORT
THERE. ARE AT LEAST CALL THE
SAME PROCEDURE IN. HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION OTHER ANY
WITNESSES HERE ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. LISTED TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY FORCING
NONE I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY IN
OPPOSITION OF. SB THIRTY FOUR
SOME MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT.
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY FOUR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHEN OPPOSITION
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DANCING THE HANDS UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTY FOURS MOVED
TO DISPENSE COUNTER. NEXUS BE.
ACCEPTED SAYS P. THREE FOUR
NINE BY CENTER- BURKE. WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA ETHICAL TREATMENT OF
PERSONS WITH SUBSTANCE. USE
DISORDER FACT THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE. AND
THE- THE CENTER HAS WAY
PRESENTATION SO. ARE LET'S MOVE
TO THE PUBLIC. TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN. A ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THREE FOUR NINE. SEEING NONE
I SEE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM-
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT SO
MODERATE- WE PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES WAITING TESTIFYING
TELECONFERENCE LINE SUPPORT OF
S. B. THREE FOUR NINE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD
BECAUSE THE POINT OF SB THREE
FOUR NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. KEEP IT ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD BECAUSE THE
PORT AT ABOUT SB THREE FOUR
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY BAND. AND
I DON'T KNOW WHEN IT'S SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME FOR SB
THREE FOUR NINE. THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB THREE
FOUR NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED. SB
THREE FOUR NINE. PLEASE KEEP UP
THE OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH YOU CAN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FOUR
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FOUR
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. EVERY SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. HAVING HEARD FROM
THE OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT ON SB
THREE FOUR NINE SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SHOW GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
TO SB THREE SIX SIX ALSO BY
SENATOR UMBERG. AUTOMOTIVE
DISMANTLING TASKFORCE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WE WILL GO TO
START MONEY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY REPORTED. TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WATERY PLEASE KEEP
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX SIX.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PORT OF SB
THREE SIX SEX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AT
THE PORT OF SB THREE SIX SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WELL NOW
MOVED OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
SIX SIX THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SOMEBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
PLEASE SKIP ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SIX SIX.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE SIX SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SIX
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT- WE HAVE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THREE SIX SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB THREE
NINE NINE BY SENATOR UMBERG
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATES FOR
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WAY PRESENTATION.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO PRIMER WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY FORTY TWO OR
THREE DISCOVERED IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE GO UP
ANY SUPPORT FOR SB THREE NINE
NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK UP REPORT OF
SB THREE NINE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS. ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF SB THREE NINE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CAN WE SHOW NO ONE
IS SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT REMOVED OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE NINE NINE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. MOTOR PLEASE SKIP ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
SB THREE NINE NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE NINE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I SAW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE NINE NINE.
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE SB SIX SIX
FIVE BY SENATOR UMBERG
UNEMPLOYMENT POLICY VOLUNTARY
VETERANS PREFERENCE- BOB THIS
WAY PRESENTATION IS NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. SHERMAN
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SIX. FIVE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF THE
PORT OF SB SIX SIX FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN. SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT'S SUPPORTER. I'M SORRY HE
SHOWS NO I SHOW NO ONE- SUPPORT
OKAY THANK YOU FOR MOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SIX FIVE
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES OR
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY PLEASE COMPANY
OPPOSITION NOW IS THE
OPPORTUNITY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SIX
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX SIX FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME.
AND I DON'T KNOW ONE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND
SEEING NONE AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
SIX FIVE OR GO TO SUSPENSE.
CENTER ALLEN IS THREE BILL
STARTING WITH SB FORTY FOUR.
WHICH IS ON THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
STREAMLINED JUDICIAL REVIEW.
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND THERE'S
NOBODY REPORTED TO A THREE
THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY- MODERATE RISK OF ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FORTY FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF SB FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
IN A CUBICLE THE LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONICA YEP THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE I
TRADE COUNCIL. IN THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE TO
MARIN CUTER COLLABORATORS ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE NINETY ONE NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINETEEN
YOU TOOK YOURSELF OUT OF QUEUE
YOU WANNA PUSH YOURSELF BACK IN
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE MAXIMO BONTA
ONE NUMBER SIXTY SIX POINT
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
REMEMBER. INJURED ANTS WE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. UNDER
THIS BILL MATCH BURKE BOARD
WHEN IT COMES UP WITH. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT SB
FOUR FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE SHOW
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE. FOR
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB FORTY FOUR-
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN FORTY AND
TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE Q. OF
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB FORTY FOUR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE ONE IN
Q. ONE ONE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I JUST HEARD FROM THE
CUMBERLAND THERE SHOULD GROUP
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SB FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE IF YOU'RE A
LOT OF TIME. AND WE SHOW NOT
ONE OFTEN CUTER. ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN A SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES FIRST
BEFORE YOU FORCING THE HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FORTY
FOUR. VOTER SUSPENSE MOVING ON
TO SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT ON
CALIFORNIA'S GREAT WORKFORCE.
BY SENATOR ALAN HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE PLEASE QUEUE UP
THE SUPPORT. FOR SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD BECAUSE A PART OF SB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE TO IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THE
COLLABORATORS. NINE FORTY LINE
IS OPEN. HI MONICA LIVE IT WILL
CATER TO THE RISE OF ANIMATION
IN FAVOR OF SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONE ONE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ON THE MANAMA'S AFFECTS
PROFESSIONAL COME UP ANGELES.
CALIFORNIA- BY THOSE OF THE
SPECS NUMBER NINE- THE SPECIES.
THE NEW. AND AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. I SHOW NO
ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN. FROM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
TO UP THE OPPOSITION. FOR SB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT. AND FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO SPEAK OPPOSITION
FOR SIX TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I IT'LL BE JUST ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE A MODEL PERSON
QUEUING OUT.
AND I'M SORRY
WE'RE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES RIGHTNOW TO BE
JUST A MOMENT TO APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE.
PINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI YES I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU HEARD ME EARLIER
THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES BUT
I AM IN FAVOR OF SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT YOU GUYS ARE CALLING IT
THE PRIOR ONE SB FORTY FOURTH
BUDGET ONE MAKE SURE YOU NOTED
THAT NINE O'CLOCK LOCATED
PROVIDE. ANIMATION THANK YOU.
BROWN OPPOSITION TO SIX TWENTY
EIGHT RIGHT NOW. AND AGAIN IF
YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE NOT THEM ZERO. OF
SECRETIVE WORKFORCE THIS TIME
THERE IS AN ALARMING QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ON SIX TWENTY EIGHT
AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX TWENTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR ON
GUARDIANSHIP AND
CONSERVATORSHIP I SENATE AROUND
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION THERE ARE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT THE COMPANY REPORTED
TWO OR THREE THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE SUPPORT. FOR SB
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. AND IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT THEY ARE WITH OPERATORS
WHO WILL BE JUST A MOMENT I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. MY
DEGREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN NINE
ONE NINETY THREE. HELLO MY AME
IS CODY I'M A CONCERNED CITIZEN
WITH THE PRE BREAKING THE BANK
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
STE SB SEVEN TWO FOUR WHICH
WILL PROVIDE CONSERVATIVE WITH
THE RANK YOU IN ATTORNEY OF
THEIR CHOICE ON CHOICE AND I
CAN'T NEXT AFTER SOME- IN TERMS
OF FINANCE BUT- THANK YOU. AT
THE CENTER OF MY ONE OUT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WELL MOVED
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY AROUND TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATE PLEASE KEEP UP THE
OPPOSITION SB. SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. AND EVERY ON OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE FIRST
ONE THEN. ZERO AT THIS POINT
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION A SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP THAT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. THE NEXT
COUPLE BILLS ARE MINE STARTING
WITH SB FORTY FIVE ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER IN DROUGHT PREPARATION
FIVE PROTECTION BOND ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO LIVE WAY
PRESENTATION. I DO NOT HAVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BATTERY
PLEASE GO UP TO SUPPORT FOR SB
FORTY FIVE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IT'S ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
NINE TWENTY THREE. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YEAH INTERNET MODELING
COOPER- FROM NIELSEN MONEY ON%
BEHALF OF MARIN COUNTY
IMPORTANT. NINE ONE TWENTY
ADELINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WITH THIS BOX
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF SACRAMENTO
AND SUPPORT. NINE ONE NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I JUST
SPOKE ABOUT LEADERSHIP GROUP WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WILLIAM AT THE BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE TREE CARE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
NINE ONE EIGHTY WHY NOT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI A I
CAN'T BE SAFER SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
IN SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATS SUPPORTS THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION NOW-
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS
HAVING TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE
GIVE ANY OPPOSITION TO SB.
FORTY FIVE. AND AGAIN IF YOU
AREN'T UP AT OPPOSITION OF SB
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
BUTTON ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO. AT
THIS POINT THERE IS NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY
FIVE SEEING NO HANDS GO UP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FORTY FIVE
ABOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON THIS
BEFORE FIVE SEVEN ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT SYSTEM
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIOS THE
DIVESTITURE FROM TURKEY. ALSO
BY ME I DO NOT HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. AND I WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A
SUBSISTENCE CANDIDATE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE AND SUPPORT SOMEBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
MODERATELY SKIP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIVE SEVEN. AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. MISTRUST ONE NOT
BAD NOT LIBERAL IF YOUR IN
SUPPORT. TELL ME JUST A MOMENT
THEY ARE WITH OPERATORS.
THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE OF A JUST
A MOMENT. NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY
SIX. ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE ONE
THIRTY SIX HAS REMOVED HIMSELF
AT THIS POINT THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE. OPPORTUNITY NOW MOVES
OPPOSITION THERE ARE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THAT WILL
SHARE THEIR THREE MINUTES-
JENNIFER BAKER LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
INSEPARABLE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION- LET YOU
GUYS DECIDE WHO GOES FIRST AND
YOU'VE GOT THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
PRIME BOOKKEEPING ON THE OF THE
TEACHERS. IN MY TESTIMONY
BECAUSE THE FISCAL IMPACT.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVEN LIMON THE
ABILITY YOU HAVE PUBLIC AND
CENTER TO ACHIEVE AND TARGETS
AND- THE LONG TERM FOR IT
PASSED THIS IS THE RETURN
SYSTEM. ACCOUNT TO THE PAY ON
THE VIRTUAL CARE THE RED OF
AGGRESSIVE IN THE PORTFOLIO BUT
THE PROPOSED. THE PORTFOLIO
WITHOUT INVESTMENT DIFFICULT
ISSUES ARE CONTROLLED BY THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT WOULD BE
UNABLE TO ACCESS BUT HAVE
LIMITED ACCESS TO THE PRIVATE
MARKET INVESTMENTS. SUCH AS
REAL ESTATE PRIVATE EQUITY
BECAUSE EVEN SOME OF THE
HIGHEST EARNING ASSET CLASSES
IN THE CHARACTERS PORTFOLIO
pHAVE LOWER INVESTMENT RETURNS
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE HIGHER
CONTRIBUTION RATES FROM THE
STATE AND THE COMPLIANCE. WITH
CONTRACT ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
THE STATE TO DECREASE THEM
CLOSER CONTRIBUTION RATE HAS
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN RECENT.
STATE BUDGET. APPLE AND HIGHER
AN IN IN RIGHT DUE TO THEIR
QUICK PHOTO. POSTERS BAKER
THIRTY FOUR CORRECT THEN FOR
THE NOT. TO OFFSET THE SIMPLER
BECAUSE FUNDS BY A BILL. THE
STATE WOULD BE. FOR MAKE UP THE
BED. IMPLEMENT BECAUSE OF
SENATE BILL. SEVEN RAIN FROM
LEAST. FOR TO ONE BILLION
DOLLAR. WHAT HAPPENED UP SILENT
WILL OPPOSE SENATOR PERFECT
SEVEN AM HOPE BOUNCE TEN
BILLION OF BETWEEN PRESENT SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JENNIFER
BAKER REPLICATE THE CAL READ.
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION OF
ARCHITECTS TO THE MEASURE FROM
OUR BELIEF THAT SHE TO MEET
TEACHERS SHOULD NOT. OPEN CRIME
MEASURE AT BEFORE COULD SEVEN
BUT IN. BENEFIT HE TICKET.
FINAL MORE CALL DOES INCLUDE A
COMPLETE A RITE OF THE- THAT
THE HIRING BEST STRUCTURE.
ATTENTION WHITING OUT WHEN IT
LAUNCHED ARAMBULA. THING CAL.
CONTRACT THE MINISTRY OF A
COPPER TO THAT MEASURE IT AT.
BY CALC TO BE IN THE HUNDREDS
ALONG OF DOLLARS IN ME REACH
BUILDING DOLLARS ACCORDING TO
INITIAL ESTIMATES. TO PUT CON
IF THE LEGISLATURE STATE WHICH
TO BUY DOWN THE COURSE
CONTRIBUTION RATE ORANGE COUNTY
CALLER RECORD. FOR THE FISCAL
TWENTY CHILDREN TWENTY THREE BY
TWO. THE COP COULD BE A PART.
SEVEN FORTY DOLLARS WHICH COULD
BE A RAT HEATED THAT PASSAGE OF
THE MEASURE SHOULD CHARACTERS
NAY TO LOWER RATE WE- YOUR
THERE IN A- TO RUN BACK UNDER
THE CURRENT. THEY HAD TO
REGENERATE IT. THE COST FOR THE
PLAN. EAGERLY NEED ONE THE
STATE NOT TEACHERS RETURN
FUTURE WILL ASK FOR YOUR NO.
THAT MEASURE TAKEN OFF OP THANK
COUNTER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND I GAVE YOU GUYS AND I
THIRTY SECONDS. ALL RIGHT-
SEEING NO ONE L. IN ROOM OPPOSE
SCENE AND NO ONE IN FOUR.
MODERATE GO TO THE PHONE LINE
AND SEE IF ANY ELSE OF TO B.
FOR FIVE SEVEN. AND MAY DEPEND
ON MAN I'M A FORMER OF YOUR
OPPOSE TO S. FOUR FOR FIVE.
PLEASE FOR ONE THAT THERE.
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AND WE
LINE TO FOUR YOUR LINE OF.
MISTER MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTY MOM HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
PROTECTION FIRE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION. AND I BE JUST
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE ONE MORE-
WE HAVE LAW FIFTH SIX CAROLINE
IS OPEN. AFTER MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE CA HISTORY GOING MARTINEZ
CLEAN WITH CAL STATE ARE. TO IN
OP THANK YOU. I'M NOT HE AT
THIS. ALL RIGHT FOR THE UP TO
FOR BOTH NOT. ON S. B. FIVE
SEVEN NO GO UP ABOUT AND- THAT
BILL WILL GO TO SUS. MOVING ON
THE SB SEVEN. ALSO ME I'VE WAY
PRESENT IT'S SUSPEND CAN. AND
THAT THE WITH- CRIMINAL LAW AND-
THE POWER WAY SHOOTING- PLEASE-
LET'S. THERE'S NO PRIMARY WHEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
SHOW ME ROOM TWENTY FOUR.
MISSION MADAM PLEASE QUEUE UP
THIS FOR S. B. SO FIFTEEN. AND
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAT THERE ARE IF YOU ARE AN
FOR. OF B. SEVEN FIFTEEN. AT
THIS TIME THERE IS NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD OFFICE
THERE NO PRIME WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE
QUEUE UP OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN. AND IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FIFTEEN
RESPECTFUL NOW THAN THAT ALL.
AGAIN PRESS NOW THAT THAT THERE
ARE FOUR BOB FOUR F. SEVEN
FIFTY. IF YOU ARE NOT THE. ME
JUST A MOMENT LOCAL ARE IN.
WITH COLLECTOR NUMBERS FROM. WE
HAVE ONE TO FIVE YOUR LINE OF.
THANK YOU CAROLYN MEMBERS THIS
IS ROY GREAT BUT ON THE APCALIS
RIGHT AND PISTOL SHOOTS REMAIN
ROCK CAL. STRONG OPPOSITE THANK.
THAT'S ANOTHER MOMENT. MINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE OF OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR THE SYSTEM MANA
pVENTURE OF THE- SUCK SOUTHSIDE
WHEN CHAPTER CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL SO AND AN ARGUMENT
MEMBERS UP. THANK YOU UNLINED
THEIR ARE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU WITH THE CARLENE L. A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDLANDS OF ASSOCIATION
NATIONAL RIFLE. I'M A COME
FOOTBALL SHOOTER AND MY OF
SEVERAL- GONNA OR- IN STRONG UP.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY YEAR
LINE OF THE- YES WITH YOUR
MEMBERS OF THE FOR THE RED
DANRY WITHOUT RIFLE. ALL YOUR
OTHERS ARE TODAY AND UP THANK
YOU. MY ONE ALSO NEARLY OF
THOUGHT. HELLO MY NAME.
STEPHANIE SO. AND I'M CONCERNED
CITIZEN AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NINE ONE NINE I'M SORRY. I'M
NOT THE- ONE NINETY SEVEN LINE
IS ALL. MY NAME IS JAMES WEST I
AM A MEMBER OF THE L. COUNTY
AGAIN SOCIAL SYRUPY- IN OUR A
AND ALSO THE SIX AMENDMENT-
THEY I STRONGLY OF THIS BILL.
AND I ALSO OPPOSE. SB. SEVEN
FIFTEEN. TELL ME ONE MORE
MOMENT PLEASE FOR ONE MORE AND
IN Q.
ONE ONE Q. DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT THEY ARE. ALL RIGHT GOING
ONCE GOING TWICE WE WILL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT WE'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ON SB SEVEN FIFTEEN
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO SENATOR
RUBIO AS ONE TWO THREE FOUR
BILLS ALL SUSPENSE CANDIDATES
AND THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION ABOUT SB SEVENTY
TWO ON PROPERTY INSURANCE
WILDFIRE RISK- THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. SINGLE IN A
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WILL MOVE
ON TO SB TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE OPERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP SUPPORT FOR SB SEVENTY
TWO. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
MET THEM THERE ALL. AGAIN PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT. ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IN
ACCORD- SB. SEVEN TWENTY FOUR.
THE SEVENTH NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB SEVENTY TWO
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE OPPOSITION
SB SEVENTY TWO. MAYBE ON
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION.
ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HE RIGHT SB. SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. GOTCHA THE LAST
TIME. AND AT THIS POINT NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTY
TWO THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS OPEN TWENTY FORTY
PLEASE COMPANY OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVENTY TWO. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEY'RE
ALL. FIVE ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION. DESPITE
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVENTY TWO GOES
TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT ON UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY
FORTY LETTER PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT. AND FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEM
ZERO. AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OKAY
JUST A MOMENT. NINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MARKED THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. FIND TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS OF THE FACTORY WOMAN
WITH THE DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER. BONTA REGISTRATION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU. NINE
TO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOR A BUSINESS SAID THOMAS ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED WAY OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES WE ARE
CALLING ON THE COURT THANK YOU.
AND NO ONE ELSE HAVE QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT NOW IT'S GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THIS
COMPANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
PLEASE KEEP UP THE OPPOSITION
SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT. AND IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION FOR SB SIX
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEY'RE ALL. WE TRUST ONE
MET THEM THERE- IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. SIX SEVEN
EIGHT. AT THIS POINT NO ONE IS
IN QUEUE ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SEEING NO.
TAKERS AND NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB SIX EIGHTY TWO ON
CHILDHOOD CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND RACIAL
DISPARITIES. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY PLEASE
KEEP UP THE SUPPORT FOR SB. SIX
EIGHTY TWO. YOUR IN SUPPORT FOR
SB SIX EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE THAT THEM OF THEIR OWN
YEAH PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
ARE A PART OF SB SIX. EIGHTY
TWO. FIND FIFTY ONE THAT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO KITTY ANGEL
CHILDREN NILE CRUISE THEIR IN
CORDOVA. THANK YOU. FIND TWO
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATE AND
SPORT SB. SIX EIGHT TWO. THANK
YOU AND THAT'S NOT ALL THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE ON OPPOSITION OF SIX
EIGHTY TWO THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINE. IF YOU ARE
AN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU AT THIS
POINT ALL RIGHT WE'VE PROVIDED
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
EIGHTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ONTO SB SIX NINETY ONE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX LAW. ON
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT. A
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
SENATOR RUBIO AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SOMEBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE THEIR
COMPANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATE PLEASE KEEP UP THE
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX NINETY ONE.
FIGURE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
NINETY ONE NOT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL AGAIN FOR THE
SUPPORT WE WANNA THEM THEY'RE
ALL. JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE
COLLECT. BUT MEMBERS FROM ALL.
THANK YOU IN UP IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT. NINE ONE EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT YOU
CAN'T BE RETARDED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA- SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS POINT THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE ON OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX NINETY ONE. THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THIS
COMPANY TWENTY FORTY POLICE TO
UP THE OPPOSITION FOR SB SIX
NINETY ONE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX NINETY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WHY
NOT BUT I'M ZERO. EMAIL WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT. I'M GONNA BE
JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. NINE TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY
MY NAME IS MELODY PRESTO AND.
IN MY CURRENT. YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. OKAY OKAY HI MY
NAME IS MELODY PROPPED ON
CALLING FROM UNITED WAY OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ATHLETES. NINETY
ONE. WE ARE ON OPPOSITION
DESPITE. GO AHEAD. I'M JUST
WANTING IN ON OUT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING
TICKETS FOR IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX NINETY ONE INCHING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
TO SENATOR NIELSEN'S- SB
SEVENTY SIX ON EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES BINDING ARBITRATION
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB SEVEN THE SIX. AND
IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEM THEY'RE ALL. WE HAVE ONE
TO EIGHTEEN AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TO EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I ADELINE TO
EIGHTEEN HAS REMOVED HIMSELF
FROM Q. I'M NOT LYING TO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS A LOCAL WEEKLY CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PROVIDERS
ORGANIZATIONS WITH SPONSORS OF
THE BILL WOULD ACTUALLY WILL
SAVE THE STATE MONEY BECAUSE
THE COST OF ARBITRATION
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN THE
COST OF LITIGATION. AND THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT MUGAR OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
REPORTED TO A THREE DIGIT
NUMBER IN TWENTY FORTY. WE SKIP
ANYONE OPPOSED SB SEVENTY SIX.
AND IF YOU ARE OPPOSED TO SB
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. YOU CAN UP YOUR
OPPOSED SB SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE NOW BEEN THERE ALL.
THERE'S NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVENTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WILL TAKE THE FIRST OF FOUR
SENATE MCGUIRE BILLS. SB
EIGHTY. AND HOPEFULLY SERGEANTS
HE'S ON HIS WAY TO PRESENT NEXT
BILL SO S. B. EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN
REQUIRING COMMERCIAL FISHING.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S
WAY PRESENTATION SNOW PRIMARY
WITNESSES. AND THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ON
TWENTY FORTY FISCAL UP THE
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY. AND IF
IT ON SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT THEM
THEY'RE ALL. AT THIS POINT NO
ONE HAS BEEN KILLED ALL RIGHT
WE GOT OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY.
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FOURTY. BATTERY PLEASE Q.
ANYONE ONLINE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB. EIGHTY AND IF YOUR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO AGAIN
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY. AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION. AND NOW
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHTEENTH
GO TO SUSPENSE. SENATE MCGUIRE
PLEASE COME UP WE HAVE S. B.
THREE FORTY ONE WHICH IS A DO
PASS ELIGIBLE FOR NEW PASS
MOTION I UNDERSTAND YOU DO HAVE
SOME PRIMARY WITNESSES. AND
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT SB THREE
FORTY ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I A LOVE THE
JACKET SIR- FIRST AND FOREMOST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU- INTO
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK- TODAY IN THROUGHOUT THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS TRULY. ON
THIS BILL WE WOULD NOT BE HERE
WITHOUT THE ENGAGEMENT I'LL BE
VERY QUICK THREE FORTY ONE
PROVIDES THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE EXPLICIT OF
40 DEGREES BACKUP POWER RULES
FOR CELL TOWERS LAND LINE
OPERATIONS IN CABLE PHONE
SYSTEMS. IT ALSO MANDATES THE
STATE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. SHARE THE INFORMATION
THEY ALREADY RECEIVE FROM
TELECOM COMPANIES ARE NETWORK
OUTAGES TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE COST OF THE CPUC
AND CAL WE **** WILL BE MINOR
AN OBSERVABLE- AND I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY RUSS NOVAK FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION COURSE OF THE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. SPEAKING SUPPORT
THANK YOU CAN RESEARCHER VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT WILL GO TO YOUR
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. THEY
HAVE TOTAL TO THREE MINUTES.
NOW LET THEM FIGURE OUT WHO
GOES. OKAY HAVE- COREY IF YOU
DON'T MIND IS A DRESS NOW
ACTING GOOD AFTERNOON- JERIT
REVELERS- SB THREE FORTY ONE
WILL IMPROVE. OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS BY
CREATING A STRONGER OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND THE DO YOU
SEE- WHEN IT COMES TO
TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES AND
BACK UP POWER SYSTEMS- DURING
RECENT POWER OUTAGES MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS HAVE
THEIR LANDLINE TELEPHONE. CABLE
SERVICES INTERRUPTED. AND ALSO
OUTAGES OCCUR FROM TIME TO TIME
THE REPORTED DEAL YES.
DEMONSTRATING WEAKNESSES IN OUR
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATION SYSTEM-
AT THE PNC HAS NO IDEA WHEN
THESE- SB THREE FORTY ONE WILL
REQUIRE- YESTERDAY. AB I PLACE
HOW DO YOUR PROFESSIONAL WITH
YOU SEE AND REQUIRES THE PC TO
REPORT THAT INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ACTIONS TAKEN
USING THE COMMUNITY ISOLATION
OUT A SEPARATION- AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE FIRE CHIEF AND
DISTRICTS WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
SB THREE TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
YOUR TURN CORY SO THE ON THE OF
THE- STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. VERY
BRIEFLY HAVING ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT NINE ONE ONE
OUTAGES IS VITAL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRST RESPONDERS.
STRING OUTAGE MAP REQUIREMENTS
WILL MAKE THIS IMPORTANT
FORMATION MORE ACCESSIBLE MORE
GROUP PUBLIC SAFETY. ASSEMBLY
NOTE TO THE FISCAL MINOR COST
ADDRESSED BY THE ANALYSIS
RELATED TO WORK ALREADY DONE
FOR UNDER WAY. AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. R. HAVING
HEARD FROM THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THIS ROOM- THERE'S NO ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE FORTY ONE. AND IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
AFTER IN SUPPORT OF THREE FORTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. AND TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS CHRISTINA I'M ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND I MEAN JUST A MOMENT WHILE
WE GET ONE MORE HERE. I'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT I'M SORRY FOR THE
DELAY. LOOKING FOR. IS THAT
RIGHT. YEAH. OKAY MINE ONE ALL
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHURCH GIVE ME GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE PARK INVOLVES
PUMPING UP THE CITY OF SANTA
CLARITA CLARITA IN SUPPORT. AT
THIS POINT ON OUT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
SB. THREE FORTY ONE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. AND WE WILL
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
AND THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY PLEASE KEEP ANYONE ON THE
LINE A OPPOSED SB THREE FORTY
ONE. AND IF YOUR OPPONENT SB
THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. ON THE SECOND OF
YOUR OPPOSED TO THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
NINE TO FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
STEVE CARLSON FOR CTIA THE
WIRELESS TRADE ASSOCIATION
WHERE I WAS AND AMEND. AND
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVE
BEEN TAKING THE OPPOSE AND
SUPPORT OPPORTUNITIES MR BAR
WHICH WILL ANY QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE TO LIKE TO DO A BRIEF
CLOSE YES SIR- YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT AS I'VE COMMITTED
BEFORE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE WE HAD
ANOTHER GOOD MEETING WITH
INDUSTRY GROUPS LATE LAST WEEK-
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS YOU CAN
CONTINUE IN A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I APPRECIATE
YOU CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I. LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING HOW THEY PROGRESS
THANK YOU SIR AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT. YOU ARE MAKING MOTION.
HAVE A MOTION TO SAY IN THE
MICRO. YES WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR KAMLAGER AND WITH THAT
MR SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE ROLE.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO HI BATES BRADFORD.
ALL RIGHT BRADFORD FIVE JONES.
DOES NOT VOTING COM LOGGER HI
I'M LONGER BY LAYERED CASKEY HI
KELSEY OFFICER FORUMS THERE'S
FOUR VOTES WILL KEEP THAT ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHTS MISTER VERY FAT TWO
OTHER BILLS THAT YOU WAIT
PRESENTATION SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT SB FIVE FIVE FIVE ON LOCAL
AGENCIES TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAX-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AS
I MENTIONED SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION SNOW PRIMARY
WITNESSES. AND WE WILL GO TO
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE PLEASE QUEUE UP ON THE
PHONE LINE ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FIVE FIVE FIVE. AND IF
YOU'RE A PART S. B. FIVE FIVE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'LL IF YOU
WANT SUPPORT. BETTER FIND
THERE'S NOT ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WHAT OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
FIVE. THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE COVER%
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
COMPOSED SB FIVE FIVE FIVE. AND
IF YOU ARE AN ARE YOU IF YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO SB FIVE FIVE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. AGAIN OF YOUR OPPOSED TO
SP FIVE FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE. BUTTON THEY'RE ALL. AND IT
WILL BE JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND THAT PERSON HAS REMOVED
HIMSELF FROM Q. AT THIS POINT
THERE'S NOT WANTING TO. ALL
RIGHT- SO WE HAVE. TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. THAT
THEY'LL GO TO SUSPENSE BILLION
SB SEVEN SIXTEEN ON HABITAT
RESTORATION SENATE MCGUIRE
THREE PRESS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S NO
GREEN RIVER TWENTY FORTY. UNDER
PLEASE HELP TO SUPPORT FOR SB.
SEVEN SIXTEEN. YOUR IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SIXTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO M. AT THIS
POINT I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN SIXTEEN THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY PLEASE
GIVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
CLOSE. TO S. B. SEVEN SIXTEEN.
YOUR OPPOSED TO SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
AT THIS POINT THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN THERE'S NO HANDS TO GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
TO SENATOR DODD SB NINETY NINE
I COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCE
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
SENATORS WASTE PRESENTATION-
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY REPORTED TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE Q. OF
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY NINE. AND
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY NINE. FIVE ONE NINE
ZERO. THERE IS NO WANTING TO AT
THIS POINT. THERE'S NOBODY IN
Q. LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS COMPANY TWENTY
FORTY. PLEASE COVER ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
NINETY NINE. IF YOU ARE OPPOSED
TO SB NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE OF THEM. ZERO I'M AT THIS
POINT THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHTS HAVE A TICKETS FOR NOW
POSITIONS AND NO OBJECTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINETY NINE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. AS MENTIONED SB
TWO EIGHTY ONE IS NOT FOR US
TODAY S. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN BY
SENATOR DOT ON COMPLEX NEEDS.
PATIENT ACT. WAY PRESENTATION
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
HE'S GOT THE SUPPORT FOR SB.
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN SEVENTEEN.
THE PART OF SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO
AND NO ONE IS IN QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION IS
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY PLEASE GO
OF ANY OPPOSITION. TO SEVEN
SEVENTEEN. AB AND OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE BUTTON ZERO. I'M AT
THIS TIME NOBODY IS THINK YOU
SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS A
GEO COMMITTEE BILL AND SURPLUS
STATE REAL PROPERTY- THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT. AND I CAN'T
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT
THEM ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
OPPOSERS THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THIS COMPANY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED A TWENTY EIGHT. S. R.
PROCESS EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEM. ZERO AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES SB
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB ONE AWAIT
BY SENATOR HER TADO ONE STATE
HEALTHY FOOD ACCESS POLICY
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION AND IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS NOBODY
TWENTY FORTY PLEASE Q. OF
ANYONE ON SOME IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE AWAIT BY SENATOR HER TADO.
AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB. EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS. ONE WE WANT TO WEAR ALL
SB ONE AWAY I'M SORRY. FINALLY
S. B. ONE OH EIGHT. HOWEVER AT
THIS POINT NO ONE IN THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF SB ONE AWAIT THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES OUR COMPANY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE OPPOSED TO S. B. ONE OH
EIGHT. STANICA ARE OPPOSED
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON THEM.
ZERO PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
THERE'S NO ONE LIKE YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF
S. B. ONE OH EIGHT AND HEARING
NONE AND NO OBJECTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ONE AWAIT WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AS
BEFORE- TO BY CENTRE TODD OVER
THE WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO. FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE SUPPORTING US BEFORE- TO.
THIS DEALS WITH MULTI PAYER
PAYMENT REFORMS. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOLLOW TO YOU
A PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I SHALL NOT
WANT TO PARTNER. WITH IN
OPPOSITION- PRIMARY WITNESSES
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY PLEASE
QUEUE UP. ANY OPPOSITION AS
BEFORE- TO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR OH TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF US
BEFORE- TO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THE ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
THERE. ARE HAVING PROVIDING UP
TO FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
ENCINO HANDS OF MY COLLEAGUES
GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
BEFORE- TO A SUSPENSE. LIVING
ON THE EDGE BEFORE SIX FOUR BY
SENATOR RICARDO ON CALIFORNIA'S
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
ELIGIBILITY THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY FORTY
TWO OF. THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE COVER
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. C.
FOUR SIX FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF SB FOUR SIX FOR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME. AT THE TIME WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO AND- ABOUT A MONTH
NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTERNOON TURN MEMBER
MADELINE COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET MY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOUNG. M. LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SACRAMENTO TURN MEMBERS OF
WOMEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION ALSO
KNOWN AS BURKE IN SUPPORT. WHAT
BEGAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX FOR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CAN I SHOW NO ONE OF IMPORT. I
ORDERED OPPOSITION OF S. B. S.
B. FOUR SIX FOUR THERE'S NO FOR
ME WITNESSES NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
PLEASE KEEP UP THE OPPOSITION
TO FOUR SIX FOUR. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ONE IN Q.
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND TO NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE TRAM AT OUR
MEMBERS MARKET THE RIVER
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT SB. FOUR SIX FOUR. I
THINK YOU AYE SO KNOW I DON'T
THINKYOU ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR
SIX FLORENTINO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION IT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON SB SIX OH
NINE BY CENTRE TODD ON
CALFRESH. NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
COMPANY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE COVER ANY
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX OH NINE. AND
LADIES AD GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX OH NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX ZERO NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT'S SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT HAVE A
NIGHT LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX OH NINE ON CALFRESH.
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. AND LET'S QUEUE
UP THE OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX ZERO
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX ZERO NINE YOU MAY PRESS.
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION- ALL
RIGHT HAVE A TAKE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OH
NINE. ENCINO HANDS GO UP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
SHOULD GO TO SUSPENSE. BILLION
SB TWENTY ONE THREE TWO TWO ONE
BY SENATOR WIENER ON HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE TIMELY ACCESS.
CENTERS WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. AND THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. TWO TWO ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF SB
TWO TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'S ME TWO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE NINE TWO TWO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND MY TWO OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- SENATORS. MY NAME IS
DRAKE S. ONE I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE L. G. B.
CALIFORNIA. AT THE MOMENT THAT
WITH WITH THAT WORK. IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO TO ONE. THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I'M SURE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU FOR. OUR
THAT'S GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO TO ONE THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THIS COMPANY IN
TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE
OPPOSED TO S. B. TWO TWO ONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TWO ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
ONE IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WITH AN OPERATOR. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ONE ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS ERIC BAILLY I MET
BEFORE I MEAN SUPPORTIVE SB.
TWO TWO ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ARE
YOU HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TWO ONE
INSING NO HANDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWO TWO ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
S. B. TWO THREE FOUR.
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH HOUSING
PROGRAM- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SENATOR WIENER'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES OUR COMPANY REPORTED
TO A THREE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FORTY. OPERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE SUPPORT FOR
SB TWO THREE FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TO
THREE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q. ONE
ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
GREGORY CLAIM ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IMPORT. ANNEX ABOUT A LINE TO
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATHY
BROWN AUSTIN ON BEHALF OF JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU AND
SUPPORT. NINE TO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS PAUL TREATMENT EFFORT CISCO
AND I'M CALLING SUPPORT ABOUT
SPEAKING THREE FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO THREE FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
REPEAL ACTUALLY LINE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CLOSES JAN
MCCARTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THAT. REPORT
THANK. ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF S. B. TWO THREE
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FIVE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FOLLOW US ARMY
INFANTRY VETERAN SANDRA BETTER
AND WALK AND TALK IN SUPPORT
THAT GIVES. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS TIME I WOULD
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO THREE
FOUR. THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TWO
THREE FOUR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF TO BE SB TWO
THREE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO THREE FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO ONE OPPOSITION.
I HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TWO THREE FORCING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
SHOULD GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON
SB THREE FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
WIENER. BEVERAGES IT'S AN
URGENCY MATTER- THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT-
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF S. B.
THREE FOURTEEN MODERATE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO.
HAVE AT THE THREE FOURTEEN BE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE ACRYLIC OPERATOR.
TWENTY ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
FALCONS ALL THE PUMPING UP THE
CITY OF INDIAN WELLS AND
SUPPORT. ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. US ARMY INFANTRY
VETERAN FOUNDER VETERANS
WALKING PART IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BY TWO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FRIEDMAN
CHAMPION ON STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MIND IS
MUTED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
HOLDING ON TO MY TO TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS NOT AT THEIR END THE
HOSPITALITY COALITION
REPRESENTING INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THAT THAT EIGHTY ONE FOR. NINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO JIM MCCONKEY WRITTEN SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ISRAELI RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. BLIND
TO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SURE MEMBERS MIKE MONAHAN
ON BEHALF OF DE ARE YOU GO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. I'M
LOOKING AT EVERY NINE TO FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RECALLING ALL. I'M NOT
SOMETHING THEY'RE LINE TWO FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
MOVE ON A MINUTE TWENTY SIX
THANK PEOPLE ARE HOME. WE ARE
NOW. EXCUSE ME ONE TWO TWO TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
LINE IS NEEDED ONE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. BUT NO RESPONSE I'LL
BE QUOTING ONLINE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. I WOULD
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FOURTEEN
THERE'S NO. THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES OR NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS OPEN TWENTY FORTY
PLEASE. OPEN THE PHONE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
FOURTEEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FOURTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO LACK
OF TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
ONE AT ZERO ACTIVE TIME. I SAW
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE FOURTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. SB THREE
THREE NINE ASSISTANCE
CANDIDATES BY SENATOR WIENER.
ON VEHICLES ROAD USAGE CHARGE
PILOT PROGRAM. THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATOR PLEASE SKIP TO
SUPPORT PRESS B. THREE THREE
NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO BECOME SUPPORT OF
SB THREE THREE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF SB THREE THREE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE COMPOSITION OF SB
THREE THREE NINE. THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN A POSITION TO THREE
THREE NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE OF THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN OPPOSITION ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
TWO FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PRINT THE CAMEL CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CAN I SHOW NO ONE ON
THE OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
NINETEEN NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE THREE NINE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE. SB THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. ON CRIMES FLOORING
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ENGAGING IN
PROSTITUTION- THERE IS NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THE SENATORS WAY
PRESS PRESENTATION THIS IS
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NO WITNESSES IN
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANY
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE. FOR
SB THREE FIVE SEVEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE IN Q. ONE TO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL BREED IN
SUPPORT OF- UNDER WINNERS. TWO
THREE FIVE SEVEN. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE Q. CURRENT WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
PINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JAMES MCCARTY SAN
FRANCISCO RESIDENT OR-
MISUNDERSTOOD THANK. ONE TO
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROBERT CAMPBELL AND THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT OF AB SB TWO. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ONE ONE Q. ONE ON
THE PLANET. FIND TO THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
Q. ONE ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SERVICE AROUND
STAYNER IN ALAMEDA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE AT THE PORT
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
FOR SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN-
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
BATTERIES OR ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE OPPOSED SB THREE FIFTY
SEVEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE FIVE SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME MY FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS TONY
ROMA'S DALLAS BUT CAPITOL
RESOURCE INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION. ONE ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER
KENNEDY IN L. A. COUNTY AYE
OPPOSED. THREE FIFTY SEVEN. WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE IN Q.
CURRENTLY WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE TWO FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SUSAN O'CONNOR I OPPOSE. SB
THREE FIVE SEVEN. BY TWO FORTY
ONE ADELINE IS OPEN. BOB. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE
PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN AND SEEING NO
HANDS CUPPING MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB THREE
FIVE SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR WIENER'S
FIVE NINETEEN CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE THE CRIMINALIZATION.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THAT ONCE THE SPEAKERS NUMBER
ZERO TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN BY SENATOR WIENER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SIXTEEN
IN Q. WILL GO TO LIKE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS KHAN WELLS FOUNDER VETERANS
WALK AND TALK ON BEHALF OF OUR
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
BETTER MEMBERS I AM IN STRONG
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT. FIVE
ONE NINE THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS JANET MCCONNAUGHEY OF
THE SPECULATIVE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION UP TO
CRIMINALIZE NATURE SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER HERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WITH OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED PLUS LOCAL MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT SB FIVE NINETEEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS NICOLE
READY REPRESENTING A
PSYCHEDELIC SPACE A COLLECTIVE
OF TRADITION THERAPIST IN
SUPPORT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
DECRIMINALIZATION OF
PSYCHEDELIC. ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR TRYING
MY NAME IS DANIEL RASMUSSEN I
AM OF I'M GOOD SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABLED NAVY VETERAN
WHO PERFORM COURT CALENDAR
CONTACTS OPERATIONS IN SOUTH
AMERICA THE REPRESENTATIVES
WALKING TALK TO MONA OPERATION
EVE ACT THE MISSION ZERO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIVE
NINETEEN AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE BROWN
SIGNALED HE COMMANDED SEVEN
CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF THE NORMAL
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS.
TRADITIONALLY EITHER FOUNDER
ABOUT TRICKLE PEOPLE CORPORATE
MOTHER ALSO BOARD MEMBERS MIKE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. FIFTY
FIVE NINETY. FIND SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS JOINED BY ACTION I'M A 1100%
DISABLED VETERANS. ONE OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MEMBERS VETERANS WALK AND TALK
WELL AND- ZERO. ANOTHER VETERAN
GUARD WHEN I JUST. WISH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THE KNOWLEDGE MAN
OF THE BILL BUT. NINE ONE ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ERIN STATE LEADERS
RARELY I AM A RESIDENT OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. FIVE NINETEEN. FIND
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE HOBBIT ACTION PROJECT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES HELLO HI MY NAME IS
ALICIA AVERAGE I MADE SERVICE
CONNECTED NAVY VETERAN WITH A
MEMBER VETERANS WALKING TALKING
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
FIVE NINETEEN. ONE TO THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS PAUL BREEDS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT OF MY SENATOR AND AS A
FIVE NINETEEN THANK YOU. TWO
FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS BURIAL EXPANDED
WITH DECRIMINALIZED MAJOR SAN
FRANCISCO SUPPORT SB FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. TWO FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
REQUEST AND LIVERPOOL MORTGAGE
INTEREST I AM ABOUT YOUR
PREFERRED DOCTOR THANK YOU
AGAIN WANT OF THE. YEAH ARE ARE
ANYTHING THAT HURTS IN. OKAY
THE CARDS IN OUR HAND ON ON A
WORK IN UNDERSTAND A WORD
YOU'RE- FIRST. YEAH MY TO FORTY
FOUR RELY IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
RYAN MILLER MARIE CORPS VETERAN
AND FOUNDER OPERATE EVEN
EDUCATING BY ABOUT CONSCIOUS.
IN INTO SO OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
THANK YOU HER WHEN. NINE TWO OH
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN
KORAN OF I AM EIGHT CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO COSTA OF THE MEDICINE
FIVE WE ARE NONPROFIT AIMED AT
CHANGING THE NARRATIVE OF A
DIFFERENT COVERAGE TO INCLUDE
THE PLACE I'M AT AND IN THE
BUSINESS WITH THE PETITION AND
I'M STRONG IN. THIS BILL.
TWENTY TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS TAMMY TO
ADD A 100% DISABLED VETERAN-
COMES VETERANS COMMISSIONER
ELECT FIVE INVESTIGATOR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MY TO
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS REBECCA I AM A
INTEGRATION PROVIDER AND
RESIDENTS IN ENGLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I'M STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU MODERATOR
HOW MANY MORE IN THE QUEUE. TWO
MORTAR THANK. BY TWO THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
JAMES WHETHER IN A SAN DIEGO
RESIDENT IN STRONG SUPPORT
PASSED THE CUT NINETEEN. AND
TWO FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT AT THE MOMENT ALABAMA
BURKE AT THE MOVIE BETJEMAN AND
DIRECTOR OF THE FUTURE OF THE
VETERANS FOUNDATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT ABOUT. NINETEEN WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED. THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSE
THE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE
NINETEEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY WE HAVE TWO IN
Q. ONE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I NEED. I'M FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE I
NEEDED WERE HAUNTING. WHAT WE
CAN HEAR YOU NOW WE CAN HEAR
YOU NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS TONY ROMA'S DALLAS WITH
CAPITAL RESEARCH INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION. ONE ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER
KENNEDY L. A. COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION. TWO FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SUE
O'CONNOR AND I AM IN OPPOSITION
SPECIFICALLY TO SOCIAL SHARING
I CAN UNDERSTAND THE MEDICINAL
VALUES. OF THE NAME- THIS
NATURAL REMEDIES AND MEDICATION
MA'AM THIS IS NOT NAME AND
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION ONLY
AT THIS POINT. IN TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WITH NO RESPONSE LEVINE TWO TWO
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU ARE NOW. NOW WHAT ABOUT THE
NEXT OPENING I AM OF STANFORD
UNIVERSITY AND LIVERPOOL JOHN
MOORES UNIVERSITY I'M CO
INVESTIGATOR OF THE STUDY.
BOBBING I BECAME AT THE READING
MY CURRENT RECOVERY I WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN NUMBER BOB AT THE I
AND THE REST OF MY- OUR ENDS.
FULL BODIED SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. IF NO ONE ELSE YOU SIR
ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
NINETEEN AND SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
THEY'LL GO TO SUSPENSE. LIVING
ON THE SEVEN NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR WIENER. ALCOHOL
BEVERAGES MOVED MUSIC VENUE
LICENSE IN ENTERTAINMENT ZONES
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
IN Q. ONE TWO TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AGAIN MY
NAME IS. A WITH A AND IN A
HOSPITALITY COALITION
REPRESENTING INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
AND WORKED AT THE SEVEN NINE
THREE. ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF SB SEVEN NINE
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN NINETY THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN NINE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO LACK OF TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN NINE
THREE MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I SAW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HAVE A
TAKE IT'S IMPORTANT OPPOSITION.
ENCINO OBJECTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES OR NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO S. B. TWO
FORTY SIX BY SENATOR LEYVA ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OPPOSITE WAY PRESENTATION.
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO FOUR
SIX. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF
SB TWO FOUR SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO LACK OF TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN Q. ONE
TWO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I COULD AFTERNOON MARKET CARELL
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO POINT SIX.
ONE TO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN
KATHY BANON STAND ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN ATION OF
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD MAKE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
AB -- AT TWO FORTY SIX
ONE ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HI DIANA THE
MAINTENANCE ON BEHALF OF
THE TRUCK AND EARLY CLAMOR
ATTENTION CONCRETE LOOK LIKE
THAT AND BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
ARE AND QUITE THANK YOU
AT THE TIME I SHOW NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT I MOVED OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO FORTY SIX THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB TWO FOUR SIX
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO FOUR SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO LACK OF TIME
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FOUR
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IN OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR SB
TWO FOUR SIX ENSINO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO FOUR SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
TWO NINE NINE ALSO FROM SENATOR
LEYVA ON VICTIM COMPENSATION
USE OF FORCE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
-- NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE IN SUPPORT OF ANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
AS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF S.
B.
TWO NINE NINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PORT
OF SB TWO NINE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q.
ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
INTERMITTENTLY ACTIVE DEMARTINO
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY OBJECTIVES FIVE
ZERO THREE SIX CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK ON F.
B.
TWO NINE NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
SIR ALL RIGHT LET'S COULD
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINE NINE
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE SOMEBODY TWENTY FORTIES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB TWO NINE NINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO NINE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINE
NINETY MAY PRESS ZERO AT THIS
TIME NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWO NINE NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
BILL BY SENATOR EGGMAN SB TWO
FOUR SEVEN ON RARE DISEASE
OMNIBUS PERSON THIS IS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM FORTY TWO -- THREE
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT A
NO BRAINER TWENTY FORTY MINOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FOUR SEVEN BY SENATOR EGGMAN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AT THE PORT OF SB
TWO FORTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE
TEMPERATURES PARTICULARLY WITH
OPERATORS ONE MOMENT PLEASE
BY TWO THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MANY OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION
-- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
ONE TWO FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS FRED NOTE WHERE AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF PHARMA
THE PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH
AND MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
POINT SEVEN BY SENATOR EGGMAN
THANK YOU ONE FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU MY NAME
IS JACQUELINE HANK AND I'M
CALLING FROM AMERICAN SECURITY
LEAVE THE PORT OF SENATE
BILL TWO FORTY SEVEN CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
ONE ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN PATEL I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR PKU AND ALLIED
DISORDERS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT PROVIDES SUPPORT TO
PEOPLE WITH RARE METABOLIC
DISEASES SUCH AS SPINAL CANARIA
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU CURRENTLY HAVE TO
MOURN CUTER COLLABORATORS
ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN AFTER HEY CAN I
ASK YOU TO CALL AND REPORT
AT EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN
WE HAVE ONE MORE IF YOU WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE
NINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HELLO GO AHEAD
MY NAME IS PETER I AM NOW
RARE DISEASE PATIENT I WOULD
LIKE TO WORK SENATE -- START
-- THE BILL -- CENTER EGGMAN
-- AGAIN I'M OUT REGISTRATION
NOW LIKE TO SUPPORT IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SIR
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU SIR ALL
RIGHT WE GOT OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO FOUR SEVEN IS NO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THE COMPANY TWENTY
FORTY PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
OPPOSED SB TWO FOUR SEVEN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO FOUR SEVEN
FIVE ONE ZERO AT THE TIME
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK WITH SB TWO FOUR
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AT THIS TIME THE WHITE
NINETY EIGHT ONE MOMENT PLEASE
NO ONE ELSE YOUR FAX ALL RIGHT
LORD OPPOSITION ABOUT THE
OPPOSITION THAT NINE NINETY
NINE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
ABOUT I WAS NOT I'M I WAS
CALLING TO SUPPORT TWENTY SEVEN
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT PERSONAL
OKAY WE HAVE NO NOTHING TO
START THANK YOU ALL RIGHT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO FOUR SEVEN AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION OF BILLS WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB FIVE
OH SEVEN BY CENTER EGGMAN
ON MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THERE WERE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM TO GERMANY TWENTY FORTY
SURE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH SEVEN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
I SAW NO ONE IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT MOVING OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE OH SEVEN NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
PLEASE GO UP ANY OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE OH SEVEN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND I SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT SO HAVING NO SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SB FIVE A SEVEN NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AFTER WE'RE GOING TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO SENATOR MEN'S
THREE BILL STARTING WITH S.
B.
TWO SIX FOUR ON FIREARM
SAFETY ON STATE PROPERTY --
THAT IS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S
WAY PRESENTATION NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP UP
THE SUPPORT PRESS B.
TWO SIX FOUR
BEIJING GERMAN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK UP REPORT
OF SB TWO SIX FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME
AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE SUPPORT QUEUE
AND LINE TO FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD
NAME THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE
MY NAME IS HI THERE I'M
CALLING FROM THAT CALIFORNIA
FIREARMS STRATEGY GROUP IN
SUPPORT OF THAT THE CLERK
MY TWO FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE ASIAN
AMERICANS IN ACTION AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S.
B.
TWO SIXTY FOUR
ONE TWO FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THIS IS YOUR COOPER FROM NEVER
AGAIN CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT -- SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY FOUR AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET RID OF ALL THOSE GUNS NOT
JUST GO ON AND ON AT YES NAME
ATTENTION STATION THANK YOU
TWO FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THERE WAS NO RESPONSE --
ALKALINE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU I WOULD OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX THE TWO SIX FOUR BY
SENATOR MAN -- NO PRIMARIES
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWO SIX FOUR I APOLOGIZE
AB I'M HAVING A TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY DEFT TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY CAN YOU PLEASE
GIVE ME TWO MINUTES PLEASE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE
INTERRUPTION --
OKAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE
COMPOSITIONAL S.
B.
TWO SIX FOUR
OKAY SO SIR ALEX THE OPPOSITION
FOR BOTH THESE GENTLEMEN IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO SIX FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
QUITE A FEW IN Q. WHAT DO I TWO
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BIGELOW THEMSELVES WHICH YOU
WANT TO FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR MIND IS NEEDED
ONE ABLE TO HEAR YOU. ONE ONE
ONE TWO FIFTY NINE NINE TO
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
DIFFERENT DIFFICULT THESE ARE
NOT OPPOSITION PEOPLE THAT- ARE
SCREWED UP. AND THEY'RE NOT
SPEAKING ALL RIGHT. THEY WANTED
A- NEXT PERSON PLEASE. ONE TO
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CARLENE
ELLIS I REMEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
I'M A COMPETITIVE SHOOTER A
MEMBER OF THE GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA GUN OWNERS OF
AMERICA AND SEVERAL OTHER-
BROKE. AWAY ORGANIZATIONS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. NINE TWO SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DARREN
BAGWELL I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION TAKING TIME OUT OF
MY BUSY WORK TAKE A STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SIXTY FOUR SB FIFTY
FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SEVENTY ONE IF YOUR MIND
IS MUTED OR UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
AND WHAT ARE RESPONSIBLE BOTTOM
LINE FORTY FIVE LINE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND BUT THE
COMPRESSIONAL PART MAN
FOUNDATION AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. LINE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS SERVICE
TELEGRAM- I'M THE KING OF THE
SOUTH STARK REYNOLDS OUT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND I REMEMBER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU IT'S MICHAEL FINLEY
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
WHO WANT NATIONAL SPORTS
FUNDACION IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ONE TWO SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY TWO SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD.
I YES I WAS ACTUALLY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIXTY FOUR
THAT FIREARMS THANK YOU GOOD. I
ONE TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES PAPER CALLING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA BYRON STRATEGY
GROUP IN THE CURRENT AND-
FORMER. ONE TWO OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY TWO OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RON LANDER
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY YOU KNOW EMPIRE OF.
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER ON BEHALF
OF OUR FOUR HUNDRED FAMILY
MEMBERS- WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS SB. THREE SIXTY FOUR. THE
WIND TO TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE TO TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
MUTED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
AND WITH NO RESPONSE FROM TWO
TWENTY FIVE WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. KERMAN MEMBERS REGULAR
PUSH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WERE STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE MOVE ON THE LINE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY ONE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BY
TWO SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES CAN'T CAN.
I MET WITH THE PORT BELUM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
I FEATURED SIXTY FOUR THIS IS
JULIA WITH THE WOMEN FOR
AMERICAN VALUES AND ETHICS AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TWO
SIXTY FOUR. I WANT TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE CAN
HEAR IT ALL BUT- AT YES I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION- I'M A
CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF
YOU WSH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO SIX FOR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ZENO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS B. TWO SIX
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB SEVEN NINETEEN AND
SURPLUS LANDS- ALSO BY SENATOR
MAN HE'S WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
WHO NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY. POLICE TO OF
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETEEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO PICK UP THE PART
OF SB SEVEN ONE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE ONE AND YOU CURRENTLY
FIND SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IF YOUR MIND IS NEEDED
WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. OKAY.
WE GARY IT IS A DAIRY WITH
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION I
DID NOT GETTING THE LINE NUMBER
ON TWO SIXTY FOUR BUT I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION GUN
OWNERS TO CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
HI WE'RE ON SEVEN NINETEEN
SUPPORT. RIGHT NOW. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION FOR SEVEN
NINETEEN THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY AND- TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE. ON
THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO
SEVEN NINETEEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THAT NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM THE
SPORT IN OPPOSITION AND SEVEN
NINETEEN AND SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
NINETEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON SB SEVEN SIXTY THREE
BY SENATOR MAN ON SENTENCING.
AND MILITARY FAMILIES. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAVE PRESENTATION. AND
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE IN SUPPORT. NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR
MEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PORT
OF SB SEVEN SIX THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE ALL OF MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN DYING
AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN. AND ON
BEHALF OF MY SON ALEXANDER
VALIANT NUMBERS DISCHARGED U.
S. ARMY SPECIAL FORCES VETERAN-
SORRY DIDN'T SEE KIANA I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE OF THE PORT OF SB
SEVEN SIX THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO APPETITE. LET NO ONE
OF IMPORT. ALL RIGHT LET'S
COULD OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVEN
SIXTY THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO IS
SUPPOSE. OPPOSED SB SEVEN SIX
THREE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO PICK IT UP. SB
SEVEN SIX THREE THEY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD BEGIN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SIX
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN THIS IMPORTANT STEP
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY SYNCING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT A
OPPOSITION. SB SEVEN SIX THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO
SENATOR RAZA WAS ONE TWO THREE
FOUR BILLS SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THE ONE BILL DOES
HAVE SOME PRIMARY WITNESSES.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON SB TWO
SEVENTY- PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
LABOR RELATIONS- THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SHE IS WAY
PRESENTATION. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OF THREE IN
SUPPORT THIS IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT THE COMPANY IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. IN SUPPORT AND
MODERATOR FEW COULD GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT PRESS BE
TWO SEVENTY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO PICK
UP A PART OF SB TWO SEVENTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND I CURRENTLY HAVE TWO INQ.
ONE TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS
MIKE MONEGAN I'M BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE I CRINGE
COUNCIL. IN THE WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN ACCIDENT
ON THE LINE NUMBER TO TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SUBBUNDLE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE ELSE OF SUPPORT AT
THE TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SEVENTY. I
SEE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM. I SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE PLEASE GIVE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE- A OPPOSED TO SP
TWO SEVENTY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SEVENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ABOUT. SB TWO SEVENTY
THEY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION CHINO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OPPOSITION
FROM MY COLLEAGUES IS B. TWO
SEVENTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING SB THREE TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR RAZA UNEMPLOYMENT
SAFETY STANDARDS HOUSEHOLD
DOMESTIC SERVICES THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE- SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM- THERE'S NO BRAIN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE IS FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY ONE.
LADIES BECAUSE SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR. ALL RIGHT KEEP GOING
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS UP AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON RICHARD MACHADO
DEAL ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND
STOP THE COURT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH IS BECAUSE THE PART OF
SB THREE TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWENTY
ONE. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THAT FROM IN TWENTY FORTY.
THERE IS ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OPPOSE SB. THREE TWENTY ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THE NEW ZERO AFTER THE TIME.
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE TWENTY ONE AND SEE NO
OBJECTION FROM MY COLLEAGUES SB
THREE SEVEN THIRTY ONE WHAT
WHICH TO ME S. B. THREE TWO ONE
THERE'S A TYPO HERE. ON EARTH
IN THE WRONG PLACE SB THREE TWO
ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB SIX THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR RAZA ON MINIMUM WAGES.
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES WE DO
HAVE PRIMARY WITNESSES ON THIS
ONE AND THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL- IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO TO
OUR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES MR.
ERIN CARRUTHERS FROM CAL STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND GREGORY
KRAMMER- KRAMER WITH
DISABILITY- RIGHTS. WILL START
WITH MISS GARAGE. WE HAVE
MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WHO OTHER EXACTLY DIRECTOR THE
STATE K. ON THE DISABILITIES
THE COST OF THIS BILL COME FROM
TRIGGERING. ONE OF THE CAUSE
CREATED BY THE BILL AND AS THE
CAR THAT ARE ASKED ABOUT THE-
IN THE PALM OF THE PRO. THAT
ARE COSTS IN BILL BUT JUMPED ON
THE BALLOT OF THE BILL THE
STATE OF. I'M GOING OF THIS
BILL MY AND SO BUT OUR AGENCY
THOSE. IF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DO YOU BEST NEED TO BE LEADING.
OTHER CRITICAL. WILL SERVE MY
AND ABSORB WHAT DO YOU TO OUR
ORGANS. PRIORITIES AN EXISTING.
FOR THE COST. BUT ACROSS. AND
SERVICES MADE BY OPPOSITE. BUT
WE BELIEVE IN IDEAS- THAT WOULD
BE. WHEN THE- AN WHICH IS ACT
ASKED ABOUT THIS BILL- IT WOULD
NEED THOSE COSTS FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS WOULD NEED TO REQUEST
IN THE FUTURE. SO IT'S PRETTY
TO INCIDENT WITH. IF NOT YET
BEEN PUT. THANK YOU COMPUTER.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT NEXT
SPEAKER. MISTER HIM YEAH WE CAN.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIRMAN GREG
KRAMER BEHALF OF DEBTS OF RIGHT
CAL. AND WE'RE TO CO SPONSOR
SENATE BILL SIX THEIR NINE
WOULD PAGES. ASSEMBLY WAGE FOR
WORK WOULD JUST. CALIFORNIA'S
ARE DISABILITIES ARE ABLE TO BE
PAID AT LEAST MINIMUM WAGE THE
LONG TERM ECONOMIC IMPACTS
WOULDN'T INCLUDE ECONOMIC SELF
SUFFICIENCY FOR EMPLOYEES AT
POTENTIALLY REDUCE RELIANCE ON
STATE AND FEDERAL SERVICES THE
REMOTE THAT SOME OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION COST MENTIONED
WITHIN THE ANALYSIS MAY BE
UPSET WITH ANTICIPATED FEDERAL
FUNDS UNDER THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN FOR OTHER FEDERAL
RESOURCES. TO LOOK FOR THE
CONTINUING WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS ADDRESS
THE PROJECTED COST REFERENCE TO
MEET OUR GOALS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WORKERS WITH DISABILITIES
DESERVE EQUAL PROTECTION UNDER
THE LAW INCLUDING LABOR WHAT SO
THE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THAT SPEECH. SIX
THIRTY NINE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM OUR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES- THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM TO TESTIFY
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIX THIRTY NINE.
LADIES GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE TO
SPEAK OF AB SIX THREE NINETY
MAY PRESS ONE TO. AFTER TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN Q. ONE TWO
OH ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTOR
PLAYED THANK YOU SO MUCH. ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILLIAM UP TO
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
THE ADMINISTRATORS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD BECAUSE SUPPORTER SB SIX
THIRTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND IF NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT THERE. ALL
RIGHT REMOVED OPPOSITION FOR SB
SIX THIRTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
SIX THIRTY NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU LIKE YOU CAN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX THREE NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WANT THEM THERE- TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
THREE NINE. I HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
MINCING NO OBJECTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX THIRTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO S. B.
SEVEN THIRTY ONE ON CRIMINAL
RECORDS RELIEF. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE NO PRIMARY WIN
THERE'S NO IN ROOM KNOW INTO
FORTY. THERE IS THERE ANY ON
PHONE LAW SUPPORT OF US B. SAID
THIRTY. LADIES AND IF YOU WERE
TO SPEAK OF PORT AT SEVEN THREE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THIS TIME. BECOMING TO AND- THE
COMPANY WITH OPERATORS MOMENT
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE PLAN THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS THAT RODRIGUEZ WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION APART
CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE. DECEMBER
COMMITTEE TIME ABOUT TO READ
OUT THE LIST OF SUPPORTERS ALL
RIGHT WE'RE DONE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. HELLO
BLAMES LEGAL AID AT WORK.
PROJECT ONE EIGHTY. EIGHT THEN
ACTION EAST BAY- COMMITTEE
THANK GOD. REALLY CHANGE.
YOUNGEST COURT RIVERSIDE
JUSTICE TABLE CALIFORNIA
RELIGIOUS ACTION CENTER OF
REFORM JUDAISM ALL RIGHT TEMPLE
BACK MUCH OPTIONS. WE'RE GONNA
KEEP NEXT PERSON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS. HERE ON OF THE ACCOUNT
RELIGIOUS ACTION CENTER WILL
TO. REPRESENTING A HUNDRED
REFORM CONGREGATION THAT ARE
UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND CORN
CHOOSING CALIFORNIA- STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE TWO FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M SURE MY
NUMBERS A LITTLE. I'M
REGISTERING STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
MORGENSTERN'S LOS ANGELES IN A
PARTNERSHIP LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN BECAUSE
OF THE TRAINING BUT TIME FOR
CHANGE FOUNDATION ARE SEARCHING
LESSONS WERE FINISHING.
REPRESENT JUSTICE. YEAH GEORGE
ACTION CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGENTS VERY COLLECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU EXPERTS.
WE DO HAVE MORE Q. ACROSS WITH
AN UPPER ONE PLEASE. BLIND TO
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH YOUR OWN STAPLE TRAINED ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANSPLANT THE
PART OF THAT SPEECH SEVEN THREE
TWO. SEVEN THREE ONE IS THAT.
AT THE YOU FOR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN. NO I DON'T THINK YOU
SIR O. OKAY ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE FOR SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED. THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO SEVEN THIRTY ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
SEVEN THREE ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. COPYRIGHT.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN THREE
ONE YOU MADE ONE AT THE TIME. I
HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT HAVE A TAKE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION SB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE WITHOUT OBJECTION THE BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON
TO- CENTER CHAU BUGS. TWO BILLS
SB TWO SEVEN SIX CENTER IN
INCOME TAX CREDIT- THAT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES HIS WAY
PRESENTATION- WILL GO RIGHT
INTO PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM- THE
SUPPORT OF TWO SEVEN SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ARE MODERATORS OR ANYONE. ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO SEVEN SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
BECAUSE SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO ONE AT THE
PORT. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SEVEN SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO S. B. TWO SEVEN SIX.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
TWO SEVEN SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
ZERO APPETITE SB TWO SEVEN FACT.
AND I SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HAVING
TICKETS FOR IN OPPOSITION AND
SEEING OF JUNCTION FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. TWO SEVEN SIX. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION ALSO BY SENATOR VOTE.
BUT CHAU BEAUCOUP IS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO
RIGHT INTO COMMONSENSE
SUPPORTERS COMPANY IN THIS
ROOM. SO MANY TWENTY FORTY. SIR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF SB SEVEN TWO
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. I WOULD OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO SEVEN TWENTY FIVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
SEVEN TWO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TWO
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
APPETITE. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MISTER CHAIR YES SIR.
I WAS OUT OF THE ROOM FOR THE
VOTE ON THE MCGUIRE BILL MAHER
WAS WONDERING IF BEFORE WE GOT
TO DO WELL I LIFT BECAUSE
BEFORE WE BREAK. ON THE TWO
BILLS OKAY WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON
CALL DO NEED TO RUN NOW. NO I
WAS GOING TO GO TO THE FLOOR
SESSION IT TOO YEAH WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A BREAK AT TWO
OKAY THANK OF JUST WELL I JUST
WANNA GET THROUGH A COUPLE MORE
BILLS AND THEN I LEFT THE
CALLS. MR ARCHER LET S. B. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN ON FIREWORKS- THAT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE HE'S
WAY PRESENTATION THEIR NOSE
FRAMER WITNESSES. AND WILL GO
RIGHT INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN TWENTY FORTY- IN
SUPPORT. OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
IN SUPPORT OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO PICK UP THE PART SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD BECAUSE THE PORT OF
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE ONE OH THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE
ON THE OPPORTUNITY FIREWORKS IN
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE OR
SOMEBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO TWO SEVEN SEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I'VE NO ONE
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HAVE A
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
TO TWO SEVEN SEVEN SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AFTER WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB THREE FORTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR GROVE ON VETERANS
HOMES. WAIT THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. IN SUPPORT OF
THREE FORTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY
EIGHT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FOUR EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THREE FORTY EIGHT.
THREE FORTY EIGHT. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF THE
PORT SB THREE FORTY EIGHT THREE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
SHOW NO ONE IS SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE FOUR EIGHT ALL RIGHT
LET'S TAKE UP. TO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FOUR
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO ZERO
AT THE TIME. IS THAT. WHAT
BEGAN IF YOU WOULD IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE FOUR EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. I SO NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE THE
THREE FORTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED
TO THREE FORTY EIGHT WE'VE GOT
OF THE PHONE LINE. SAYING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
FORTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MR JONES WILL GO TO
HIS BILL TO SWAY PRESENTATIONS.
WE HAVE SB THREE FIFTY EIGHT ON
PROPERTY CRIMES MAIL THEFT.
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE
WILL TAKE SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT.
OF THE TWENTY FORTY AND SUPPORT
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIFTY EIGHT BY MISTER
JONES. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO BECOME A PART OF SB
THREE FIVE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FIVE EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. SO
NO ONE IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSERS OF
ANY TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
THREE. FIVE EIGHT. HE WOULD
BEGIN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
FIVE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE FIVE EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I DON'T KNOW WHAT IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
AND SB THREE FIVE EIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THAT BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE- ARE GOING TO TAKE
A BREAK TO GO TO FOR SESSION
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT. I WANT
TO LIFT THE CALLS ARE FOR ALL
FOLKS WHO ARE WHICH IS WISHING
TO TESTIFY ON THE BALANCE OF
OUR BILLS. YOU'LL HAVE TO COME
BACK WHEN WE COME BACK AFTER
SESSION SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
BREAK TO GO TO WORK FOR
SESSION. AND THEN RECONVENE-
IMMEDIATELY UPON A GERMAN A
FLOOR SESSION SO EVERYBODY
WHO'S QUEUED UP. WILL HAVE TO
MONITOR THE FLOOR SESSION. AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO DO THAT
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON CALL. WE HAVE S. B.
TWO EIGHT- BY SENATOR LIMON ON
CALL MISTER. AND SO THAT YOU
COULD LIFT THE- IN A SPEECH TO
A OO. SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY OR
MON- CHAIRS GOING COURT BOTH
SICK TO ZERO BATES. CENTER BAY
IS NOT SO WE'RE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON S. B. TWO EIGHTY. AND WE ARE
GONNA TO. LIFT THE CALL ON
CENTER. OF AND THE BILL IS OUT
ON A SIXTY. VOTE WE'RE GONNA
LIFT THE COLONISTS THREE FORTY
ONE ON SENATOR MCGUIRE MISTER
CONSULTANT IF YOU COULD CALL
THE ROLL AND SB THREE FORTY ONE.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR A CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING BY.
SENATOR BATES. SENATOR JONES
SENATOR LAYER BY LAYER BY.
SENATOR JONES IS NOT HERE. HE
VOTED HE HERE- HE DID AN ABOUT
RIGHT CORRECT OKAY SO THAT BILL
IS OUT FIVE TWO ZERO RIGHT.
THAT BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO SO
WE'RE CLOSE THE ROLE ON SB
THREE FORTY ONE. AND AS I SAID
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A RECESS TO GO
TO FOR SESSION AND WE WILL COME
BACK. AFTER RECESS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS A SHORT
RECESS.
AND OF ALL THIS. THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
BACK INTO ORDER FROM OUR A
RECESS WE'RE GOING TO GO RIGHT
INTO SB FIVE SIX FIVE BY
SENATOR JONES WHICH IS ON STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HOSPITALS.
DISABILITY EXPANSION REPORT.
AND CENTER JONES IS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WE'RE GONNA RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE IS
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR I THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT SB. FIVE SIX
FIVE. DO WE HAVE OUR MODERATOR.
WAS THERE. CASE OF THE MISSING
MODERATOR. MISS MARPLE AND
HERCULE PORO TEMA.
GOING TO BE
A PROBLEM. FOR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THERE WE GO BECAUSE
THE PORT OF SB FIVE SIX FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO
WOULDN'T YOU AT THE TIME AND
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX FIVE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF FIVE SIX FIVE. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO FIVE
SIX FIVE- BUT SEEING NONE IN
THIS ROOM WE WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE OPPOSED SB FIVE
SIX FIVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIX FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IT DOESN'T. ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE SIX FIVE SIX FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
OVER THE PHONE MIGHT BE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE
SIX FIVE. MR THERE'S NOBODY
THERE OVER THERE ALL RIGHT.
HAVING TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
INSING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE SIX FIVE. FOR
MOVED TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
CENTER COPYRIGHTS TO BILLS SHE
IS WAY PRESENTATION ON BOTH.
THE FIRST ONE IS S. B. THREE
FIVE NINE. ON CLIMATE CHANGE
RESILIENCY AND- MERCED COUNTY-
WE WILL GO TO SUPPORT POSITIONS
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
SHE'S WAY TESTIMONY. AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WISHING TO SUPPORT SB
THREE FIVE NINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIVE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FIVE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I SHOW NO ONE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOBODY IN
THISROOM OPPOSE THERE'S NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE. THE
PROPOSED. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIVE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIVE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NO SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AND NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THREE FIVE NINE OR GO TO A-
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB FOUR
NINETY ON HOUSING ACQUISITION
BY SENATOR KABIRU SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. AND THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORTERS NOBODY TWENTY FORTY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
WISHING TO SUPPORT SB FOUR
NINETY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I
YOU WISH TO SUPPORT SB FOUR
NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR NINETEEN MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I SHOW
NO ONE IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED US BEFORE NINETY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR NINETY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I SHOW NO
ONE OPPOSITION I HAVEN'T TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SEEING NO
HANDS FOR MY COLLEAGUES AS
BEFORE NINETY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB
FOUR SIXTEEN BY SENATOR HUESO
ON CORRECTIONS EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. IT OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION- NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING AND SEE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK. NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE- IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR SIXTEEN. BY THE EARLY
SIMPLICITY COULD SUPPORT. OF SB
FOUR SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AT
THE PORT OF SB FOUR SIXTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THENZERO. WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. CURRENTLY WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
HELLO RATING FOR THAT LINE ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIXTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
LINE TO EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT'S NOT ABOUT IT ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIXTEEN. AND AS A
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK UP SUPPORT
BEST BEFORE SIXTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT I
WOULD OPPOSITION A SONG FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NINE- IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED US BEFORE SIXTEEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE
IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
US BEFORE SIXTEEN SING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION I WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. SB FIVE EIGHTY
ALSO BY SENATOR HUESO
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
HIGHWAYS AND ROADS. RECYCLED
PLASTIC STUDY. SPECIFICATIONS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY
THROUGHOUT HISWAY PRESENTATION
WITH THE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
HEARINGS. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO SB FIVE EIGHTY
THERE'S O ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE
EIGHTY. THE MEDIA GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I'M SORRY CHAU NO ONE
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHTS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
EIGHTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
SIX OH FOUR. BY SENATOR HUESO
ON NATURAL RESOURCES THE NATURE
AND PARKS CAREER PATHWAY- THIS
IS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S RATE
WAVE PRESENTATION WITH THE
RIGHT OF THE PUBLIC HEARINGS.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
HERE TO TESTIFY. NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FOURTEEN FORTY MODERATOR
TO HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH FOUR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX ZERO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AND I SAW NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX OH FOUR. AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
TEN ZERO ACTIVE TIME. I ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OH FOUR
PLEASE PRESS. ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT- SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX OH FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO
ON EMERGENCY RESPONSE TRAUMA
KITS. DISPENSED CANDIDATE.
PRESENTATIONS AND WAVE WE'RE
GOING RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
HEARING- OF SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN.
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX EIGHT SEVEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX EIGHT
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF THE
POINT OF SB SIX EIGHT SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I SHOW NO ONE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY. FORTY
OPPOSED TO SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SB SIX
EIGHT SEVEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX EIGHT
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE
NO ONE TO OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM THE PHONE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO SENATOR BRADFORD
ONE TWO THREE FOUR BILLS. A
GOOD CENTERS WAY PRESENTATION
AND HAS NO PRIMARY SPEAKER
SUPPORT PROPOSED OF A WRITING
TEST BEFORE NINETY THREE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FINANCING
JUVENILE JUSTICE- WITH THE
PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM FOR SUPPORTING FOR
NINETY THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. IN SUPPORT OF
FOUR NINETY THREE MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE THREE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR NINE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I HAVE NO ONE IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION WILL OPEN UP FOR THE
CURRENT PROPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE
THIS BEFORE NINE THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE NOT
POSITION OF S. B. FOUR NINE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE IMPERIAL
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION.
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND
NO HANDS OF MY COLLEAGUES GOING
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION IS BEFORE
NINE THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB FIVE SIX SEVEN BY
SENATOR REVEREND CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SENTENCING- THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
UP IN A PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY TO SOMEBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S FIVE SIX SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE IF ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SIX SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I SAW NO ONE IN SUPPORT. I
WOULD OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIX
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM RUSSIAN THAT MICROPHONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS FOR ANYONE ONLINE
OPPOSED SB FIVE SIX SEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE SIX SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. INTERRACIAL NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. WE OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
AND NNE OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
THEIR HANDS REYES SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX ON CRIMINAL
FEES BY SENATOR BRADFORD. WHOSE
WAY PRESENTATION AND THEN-
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC HEARINGS IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM SUPPORTING SB FIVE EIGHTY
SIX. AND THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SUPPORTING SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE EIGHTY SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN F YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHT SEX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WHAT THEY CAN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE EIGHT SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO ONE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX.
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE IS THERE ANYONE ON TE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
SIX. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE EIGHT SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
EIGHT SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE PERSON IN QUEUE FOR CALLING
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE OPEN MIND TO NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I GET
AFTERNOON SHARE- THIS IS
WILLIAM ATCHISON BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL THIS IS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE AND YOU AT THE CENTER I
HAVE AN OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY SIX AND SEEING NO
HANDS ON MY COLLEAGUES GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE.
EIGHTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB SIX OH THREE CENTER
BRADFORD ON CANNABIS LICENSING.
DEFERRAL AND WAIVER FEE
PROGRAM. AND THE TAX CREDIT-
THERE ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
OFFICE WAY PRESENT. SO RIGHT AT
THE PUBLIC HERE. AND THERE'S NO
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT YOUR
NUMBER IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB SIX OH THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX OH THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOWED NO ONE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT WE MOVED OPPOSITION- I
SEE NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
TAXI NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO OPPOSE SB
SIX OH THREE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OH THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX OH THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOWED NO ONE IN THAT POSITION.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY AT
SIX OH THREE SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX OH
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SENATOR BACKERS ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE BILLS WILL GO RIGHT
TO SB FIVE OH FOUR WHERE HE IS
WAY PRESENTATIONS. AND THIS IS
ON ELECTIONS VOTER REGISTRATION
OR NO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING. SEE IF
ANYBODY'S HERE TO SUPPORT IT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH FOUR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE OH FOUR. PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ACCESS. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE OH FOUR.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSERS NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
YEARS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE OH FOUR BY
SENATOR BACK. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE OH
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION ON SB FIVE OH
FORAGING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FIVE BEFORE WE GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB SIX FORTY ON TRANSPORTATION
FINANCE- BY SENATOR BACKERS WAY
PRESENTATION. THERE NOPE WOULD.
AND WE'LL OPEN THE CALL HARING
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
HERE TO SPEAK. ON IT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO
SPEAK ON IT IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FORTY BY SENATOR BAKER. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION ANYBODY
OPPOSED SB SIX FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB. SIX FORTY. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVING OFF
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WILL CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING AND WILL. LOOK TO MY
COLLEAGUES THERE'S NO HANDS RAY
SO WITH OBJECTION S. B. C.
FORTY. TO GO TO. MOVING ON AS
SIX NINE ON TO COLLEGE THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE. CENTER
BACKERS WAY PRESENTATION THERE
NOTE- PRIMARY SPEAKERS WILL
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO
SPEAK ON IT. AND LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S NO ONE IN TWO FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANY HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX FIVE
NINE. LADIES AND- IF WISH TO
SPEAK THE PART OF. SIX BY NINE
TWO PRESS. AND AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIVE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SPECIAL NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSERS NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS ANYONE ON THE
PHONELINE OPPOSED. SB SIX FIVE
NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX FIVE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
THIS TIME. I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
OPPOSITE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SPORT OF OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY
ON SIX FIVE NINETEEN NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
FIVE NINE BY CENTER BACK WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. SB SEVEN SIX
SEVEN BY SENATOR BACKGROUND
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY DIGITAL
EDUCATION EQUITY PROGRAM. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AS WELL
OR NO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION. WE
WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC HEARING IN
THIS ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
SEVEN SIX SEVEN. LADIES AND IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK SUPPORT SB
SIX SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN YOU WISH TO OF THE- OF S.
B. C. SIX SEVEN PRESS ONE THE-
AT THIS. WE DO HAVE ONE IN KEY
CALLING WITH A OPERATOR MOMENT
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE OPEN MIND TO NINETY
THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS ROLAND BAKER FROM
THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY OFFICE
VEGETATION AND WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. WE HAVE ONE MORE Q.
CURRENT WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE TO NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS SAM CRUZ I'M A RETIRED
INSTRUCTIONAL COOK EDUCATION
ABOUT TECHNAVIO. TECHNOLOGY OF
COORDINATOR AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. REMINDER
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SEVEN
SEVEN SIX SEVEN. THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSERS NOMINEE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED. IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SB. SEVEN SIX SEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
SIX SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I SHOW
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
AND THEN OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON SEVEN
SIX SEVEN SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN BY SENATOR
BAKER WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON THE SEVENTH SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE ON FELONY MURDER BY
SENATOR BACKER. HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. AND THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS
ROOM ON SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE.
NOBODY HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORTING. SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THE BUREAU AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN SUPPORT- MOVED
OPPOSITION WILL OPEN THAT UP
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE IS NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY. TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND I SAW
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION I MEAN
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVIG ON TO SENATOR
ATKINS HAS A BILL SB FIVE
TWELVE AND STATE HIGHWAY
RELINQUISHMENT ROUTE SEVENTY
FIVE IN TWO EIGHTY TWO. OF THE
GOOD SENATOR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARINGS IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE HERE WHICH TO
SUPPORT FIVE TWELVE SEEING NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM SIGNAL ONE
ROOM. FORTY ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE
TWELVE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD TO SPEAK OF PORT OF.
FIVE TWELVE MAY PRESS ONE AT
THE- AT THIS. WE HAVE ONE IN Q.
CURRENT WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE TO NINETY
NINE. THE LINE IS OPEN THE
GROUP HAS A BILL SB FIVE TWELVE
STATE HIGHWAY RELINQUISHMENT
ROUTE SEVENTY FIVE AND TO
EIGHTY TWO. OF THE SENATE OR
NOT HERE WE BEEN WATCHING OVER
AND OVER THAT. OTHERS HOMELESS
FOR I THINK SUPPORT. ANYONE
HERE ONE I KNOW. YES GO AND
NINE NINE OFF DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE LESS TO GO AND SPEAK TO
US THAT WE'RE UNLESS YOU'RE-
SORRY. I WANTED YOU SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF A B. FEB SEVEN FIVE.
OKAY US YOUR NAME. GENERAL
STAPLETON. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE BACK TO FIVE TWELVE IN
SOME ANY SO FOR FIVE TWELVE.
AND ONE AGAIN LADIES AND IF YOU
TO SPEAK OF SB FIVE TO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME.
AND I SHOW NO ELSE IN FOR A
FIVE OPPOSITE AS FIVE. THERE'S
NO IN THIS OPPOSE NUMBER IN
ROOM TO FORTY IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE TO SPEAK.
TO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'RE A- TO SB TWELVE MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO THIS TIME. WHAT
IF YOU ARE OPPOSED FIVE TWELVE
YOU MADE ONE THEN. AT TIME. AND
I HAVE NO WAY UP AT THE- ALL
RIGHT WE'LL SEE NO HAN GO UP
WITH OF. SB FIVE VOTER SUSPEND.
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO SB FOR.
FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR TO RETURN.
AND CO NINETEEN IN TO URGENCY
THE SENATOR AS WE PRESENT.
THERE NO PRIME WITNESS. OF A
RIGHT INTO PUBLIC TEST THAT
FIRST SIP. NOBODY IN. FORTY TWO
OF THERE NOBODY AROUND TWENTY.
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE AND- OF
SB. FIVE FORTY FIVE. LADIES AND
IF YOU TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AFTER TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING. THERE IT
WILL GO TO THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. OPPOSE
US FIVE FORTY. THERE'S NO IN
ROOM TO. FOUR OPPOSE TO. SB
FORTY MODERATORS OR ANY.
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
FOR SB FIVE FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WILL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE FOUR FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU OPPOSED
TO SB FIVE FOUR FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. CAN
I SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE
NO SUPPORT AND WE HAVE NO
QUESTION SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FIVE FOUR FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON THE SENATOR
LAYERED SB SIX OF TWO ON
CONSERVATIVE SHIPS. HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION AND THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WIL OPEN UP
PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS ROOM
SONOMA HERE. OVER TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO PICK UP OF SB SIX
OH TWO PRESS ONE THEN. AT THE
TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
UP OF SB SIX VOTE PLEASE ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS. AND I HAVE
ONE IS A- ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITE. WAS THERE'S NO IN
THIS ROOM. OPPOSED SB SIX OH
TWO THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OF. TO SEE OH TWO ANYONE
ON THE PHONE OPPOSED. SIX OH
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK OPPOSITION
ABOUT B. C. OH TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO APPETITE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU OPPOSED SB FIVE OH TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND AT THIS
TIME. AND I NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION HAVING OFF THE UP
FOR SUPPORT. SB SIX OH TWO IT'S
IN NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX OH TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB SIX SIXTY BY
SENATOR NEWMAN ON INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL
PETITIONS- HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS ROOM
THERE IS NOBODY HERE MOREOVER
MORE ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. MODERATE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX ZERO BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF SB SIX SIXTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO LACK OF
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND I HAVE NO
ONE IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WE'LL
MOVE TOP. OF SB SIX SIX ZERO BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED THIS
NOBODY IN ROOM TO FORTY A FIVE.
UP MY- ARE ON THE LINE. OPPOSED
S. B. C. SIX ZERO. LADIES AND
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION HAVING OFF
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ON SB SIX SIX ZERO.
THE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX SIX ZERO ONE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING TO SB SIX
SIX SEVEN BY SEN DR TO ME BY
GENERAL ROTH ON PROPERTY
TAXATION FOR DISABLED VETERANS
EXEMPTIONS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE GENERAL IS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
EXCUSE ME FORTY TWO OH THREE.
FORTY MODERATED TO HAVE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB. SIX SIX SEVEN BY
GENERAL RAWAT'S. LADIES AND IF
YOU WERE TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF B.
C. SIX SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
OF THE ZERO I THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT I- MOVED OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX SIX SEVEN- THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE OR
HOW MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIX SIX SEVEN BY
GENERAL ROSS. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE NOT BRITISH
OF SB SIX SIX SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOUR OPPOSED TO
SB SIX SIX SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE OPPOSED ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
ENCINO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIX SIX SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE HAVE ANOTHER. A
BILL BY GENERAL ROTH SB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE ON MEDICAL MANAGED
CARE BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE IS
THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE BY GENERAL
ROTH. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN YOU
WISH TO OF THE OF S. SEVEN
SEVEN THREE MAY PRESS OF THE-
AT TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE COMPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED TO SEVEN SEVEN THREE.
MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WISHING TO SPEAK IN. A
POSITION OPPOSITION OF SEVEN
SEVEN THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
BUREAU AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE. YOU MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO.
I HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT HAVING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE SEEING NONE AND SEE.
QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WILL MOVE TOWARD
FINAL BILL ON THIS TODAY'S
DOCKET SB SIX NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR STERN ON PUPIL
INSTRUCTION GENOCIDE EDUCATION
AND HOLOCAUST- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. AND THERE ARE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WISHING TO SPEAK
WITH ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINETY
THREE. BY SENATOR STERN. LADIES
AND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF S.
B. C. NINE THREE MAY PRESS ONE
BUTTON. AT TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX NINE THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE IN SUPPORT I WILL
MOVED OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
NINETY THREE WILL START HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
SOMEBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTIES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX NINETY THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
ATHLETES SIX NINE THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK UP A- ABOUT THE SIX THREE
NAY PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE. I
HAVE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE KNOWN AND IS. AND
WE'VE ALL THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOME OFFICE AND WE HAVE NO FROM
MY COLLEAGUE. WE WILL- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX NINETY THREE
WITHOUT ASSISTANCE- WE'VE
LIFTED ALL THE RIGHT MISTER SIR.
FOR MISTER CONSULT- SO WE'VE
DONE THAT CONCLUDES THE ALL OF
ITEMS ON THE H. THANK YOU FOR
EVERY WHO WAS PART IN THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTSOR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE ELSE WHO'S
PARTICIPATED IN THIS HEARING
AND MY COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES AND
STAFF FOR BEING PATIENT WITH
OUR BREAK. I APPRECIATE IT THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.